the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the final leg of the 2022 grand chess
tour is underway at the sinkfield cup in
st louis tour leaders face a brutal
field as they battle for remaining gct
points former u.s junior champion hans
niemann fearlessly fought american
superstar lavon ironian but the legend
definitely drew the game the world
championship rematch of magnus carlson
and ian napomniacci yielded the same
results as their title match with
carlson masterfully defeating the former
challenger magnus has the early lead but
we're just getting started round two of
world-class chess
coming up next
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
same field cup the last stop of the
grand chess tour we start a day in front
of the gateway arch as we are waiting
for the players to arrive we've had an
amazing first day what are the players
going to bring in today's round let's go
to the studio and find out with yasser
peter and alejandra
from the home of chess in america
welcome to the sinkfield cup the
flagship event of the saint louis chess
club and the final leg of the 2022 grand
chess tour
hello and welcome i'm peter swiddler and
with me is the richie benno of chess
commentary yasaseerava wow i'm not
worthy peter it's always a pleasure to
be with you but i'll have to look that
one up
trust me it's a compliment oh wonderful
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of round two with the 2022
sinkhole cup yesterday the games were
full
of content great fights i really really
enjoyed them but one
very regal effort by one magnus carlson
was it good enough to propel him into
the lead peter our current standings
after round one he also basically told
you the standards guys
and i did
yeah here they are on your screen with
the one decisive game in round one
magnus is uh on top of the world and
then there's eight people and fifty
percent uh all of them trying against uh
one another and yani palmishi is
currently uh scoreless and he will he
will
definitely want to
correct that and bounce back
as possible the format is a template
around robin uh we have a feeder time
control in place with 90 minutes for the
first 40 minutes and then 30 minutes for
the rest of the game with the uh 30
second increment starting from move one
draw offers are explicitly uh forbidden
and the
normal scoring system traditional plays
yeah exactly and our schedule people
the schedule is we play until round 5
with no breaks then there is a res day
on wednesday september the 7th and then
uh four more rounds uh with the final
round starting on september 11th all
games do begin at 1 pm central and
this year the tour dedicated as a
separate day for the potential players
which i think is a good idea i generally
as a player i always wanted to you know
not mix the time controls within one day
playing rapid against classical is
tricky i'm very supportive of that as
well and
rejoice everyone because we have
alejandro in audience alejandro good to
see you my friend pleasure to be with
both of you this afternoon calling the
action here at the singfield cup one of
the most important tournaments around
the world and certainly the most
important here in america let's take a
look at some of our players who are not
unfamiliar with winning this particular
event of course you guys mentioned that
we are right now
led by magnus carlson one point one full
point yesterday on the foundation he's
won this tournament twice in 2013 our
inaugural event where he beat uh the
players hikaru nakamura levon and
garakami was a four-player event and he
tied for first place in 2018 with levon
and with fabi as well speaking of fabi
he won it in 2014 absolutely so he had
that great run where he started seven
zip finish with an over 3200 performance
one determined comfortably a result that
has not been matched but of course we
have other winners levon aronian won
this event in 2015 as well as in 2018
where all three of these players tied
for first in 2015 levon did it by
beating up on the americans he drew all
his games but bit hikaru beat wesley and
beat fabiano and another player that's
won twice in the sink field cup maxima
sherlock round won solo in 2017 after
clinching this tournament with a white
victor against jannie pognachine and
idor and of course he is our defending
winner from 2021 the only person not in
this list because he's not participating
in this event is dean loren who wanted
in 2019 meanwhile wesley saw is the
player that won't do that in 2016 but
has not won since and i have the feeling
that
well our woman grandmaster resident
media specialist anastasia karlovic
picked wesley to win the tournament and
it might be to even things out anastasia
welcome
it's pleasure to be here and yes you are
absolutely all right alejandro the idea
was to pick up wesley saw hoping that he
will make it twice as the same
as the other winners says magnus
carsonness fabiano and the others so i
hope
i'm really rooting for him in this event
and we actually have saturday today and
um expecting many many spectators many
visitors for saint louis chess club um
unfortunately they cannot enter the
plane venue but all of them they gather
in the club they play some chess and of
course they follow the commentaries of
your team and yesterday we had really
great spectators vip guests we had
robert thomas from saint louis blues and
we also had
another vip person the rapper american
rapper logic was such a great name it's
just
so they played some games against each
other they also visited the playing hall
they met with players and we also had
this cute kid whom you can see now on
the screen he was waiting from the
morning to catch magnus carlson and get
his autograph and he succeeded at the
end so we're expecting lots of action
today and please follow our instagram
and our twitter accounts our social
media of saint louis chess club and
grand chester because you will find
there lots of information and i'm coming
back to peter and yasser because the
second round is about to start anastasia
thank you so much for all your work and
i know that you clobbered them in bug
house so that was a good job and peter
lay the table for us for this round two
absolutely uh the pairings as will be
the case uh every day as we see people
actually waiting to get wanted
but the lineup they're backing up
waiting to get wandered there's the ali
razay waiting his turn yeah but yeah
there they are the pairings for round
two uh hans niemann uh with his second
uh wide in a row very well kind of a
warm welcoming
uh start for the tournament for him it's
so it's nice nice to have a bit of a
safety cushion there as somebody who's
never really played these fields in
classical chess before right fabi is uh
white against the nerd i mean is they
worked together in the past so they know
each other pretty well right yanipon she
plays against larry reza ferocious a
very interesting pairing in which jan
generally seems to be doing well but
uh alireza is on a very very hot streak
right now
aronian versus carlson is they're
nearing their uh 200s game against each
other
wow a fantastic volume of chess played
against
played between those two and maxima
shirograph plays white against wesley so
and as we were coming into broadcast you
were mentioning that mvl actually has a
pretty dominating scorer it's uh peter
and remarkable it's truly remarkable
considering how strong wesley's and also
how solid wesley is but wesley doesn't
really lose games of chess very often
but not only is the score 6-1 in favor
of mvl uh we we checked and wesley won
that one classical game that he did win
against mvl it's in 2022 right this is
so it used to be it used to be a 6-0
score in nbl's favor until very recently
until the the grand prix
in the spring the players are going to
be fighting for two weeks and what are
they fighting for peter uh the prize
fund here as you can see is about 350 uh
and the first prize is a hundred
thousand dollars a very very nice uh
price for for the winner uh 65 for uh
second 48th for third uh and all the way
down to 10.5 uh for the last place and
of course there's a separate purse for
the winners of the gct tour which means
that those gt points on the right are
also incredibly important very crucial
indeed and
big shout out to brian priester he's
coming back with another brilliancy
prize peter absolutely and this is a
tradition which i think existed in most
top tournaments at a certain point right
and then started gradually disappearing
and it's very nice to see it uh
supported back supported here by brian
yeah it's it's his
his effort to preserve it and we we're
very grateful for that and we're also as
you could see there on the screen we're
judging
that particular competition so work uh
exactly ahead i remember the brilliancy
prize uh we we judged yes uh last year
pardon me for uh lanier he had this
absolutely crazy victory over mvl
remember that one alejandro that was so
sweet absolutely how can i forget that
that deep calculation that lanier had to
prove at some point he played a perfect
game against the night of against mvl
and it was beautiful to watch he
actually tried the same variation
against saric in this year's grand chess
tour right sarge was well prepared only
was able to hold on for a while but
dominguez beat him anyway no that was
nice it was nice so there we see
the butterflies as the players take
their seats they get ready now this
pairing in particular
nepo
coming off a loss
uh
feeling that angst to get back into the
tournament group with a victory and yet
he's going up
against a very hot player absolutely
what's the
how do you say the psychological well
first of all madness world champion
magnus is arriving let's see how he gets
wandered through uh sort of
to a degree maintaining that tradition
that i saw
i mean it's it's maybe slightly unfair
because it's not that late yet but i
remember
and i'm sure you you also recognize
probably what i'm going to say yeah
world champions taking their time in the
olden days gary used to uh
arrive maybe even like three minutes
late maybe more seven to eight in fact
because there was the five minutes for
the photographers
at the start of playing to to avoid the
crush and to avoid the right um
the people swarming his board that's
actually from extreme close range she
does which does sometimes actually uh
upset your concentration but man is
there uh still still with plenty of time
he's an old veteran at this kind of
stuff so it really does not bother him
but once you get into your mindset of
like okay let's play jazz you really
want the photographers to leave you
although yeah we all learn to to tune it
out
fairly successfully because otherwise
you know playing in public
becomes a problem if you if you can't uh
if you can't successfully
let me press you a little bit about the
napa farouja game once again because the
uh
the underlying tension the dynamics of
nepo having lost his first game
and uh
you know
meaning that he's got to bounce back
how does he put pressure on uh ali reza
i think it's uh i mean so much of the
the the very very elite chess of which
this tournament of course is a very you
know obvious representation is
heavily heavily opening related so
not everything is in your hands there
but i think it's good for him that he
plays alireza specifically because
alireza so far does not have the the
greatest record against him these things
do
uh play on people's minds a little bit
uh and he has won some important games
against the rest over over their
somewhat short history of of meeting and
he gets to play by the looks of things
he gets
a catalan which i think he will enjoy
their game in uh
yeah in the rapid than blitz
quite clearly um
jan
did not want to you know go all out
there showing perhaps
his absolute best stuff and he
for a brief moment there he was
significantly worse yes he was and that
was the game in the opening too out of
the opening as well we do in fact have a
catalan on the yawn
versus alireza game and again i was a
very dissatisfying look
as i remember uh nepo being slightly
worse and then struggling to make a draw
which he did do you know eventually
eventually he even pushed for a little
bit but yeah there was and alireza in
that game played dxe4 bishop d2c5 which
is
uh i mean everything in the catalan
these days is heavily theoretical
catalan has become a
very very mainline thing that a lot of
very top players are doing so there's
exactly there's plenty of theory uh to
go around but uh this does have uh
i don't know i won't say that does have
the advantage but i don't know if it's
an advantage necessarily of getting a
lot of pieces of the board quite quickly
and the resulting end games
might look exceedingly dry right but
they they're not always as
empty for white as uh that particular
game between these two players and they
have may have made it look
as we get
into uh the start of round two anything
in particular caught your eye alejandro
i'll be taking a look at this game
between two players that you mentioned
peter know each other very well fabiano
corona with the white pieces against
lanier dominguez specifically in a
variation that they worked on together
and i know that they worked on together
because i was also part of that team we
all worked together in this particular
file of the petrov this knight c3 petrov
specifically against bishop p3 playing
97 knight f6 uh so i'm curious on how
this one is gonna go back from the 2018
world championship match that uh favi
played against magnus carlsen we
analyzed this pretty much
until we couldn't look at the board
anymore couldn't see a petrov again and
of course dominguez back then was not a
petrov player actually put it as part of
his repertoire in later years and
fabiana himself has played the white
side of this particular position he
played it against duda i in one of our
grand chester rapidom blitz with
excellent results so i'm curious where
the deviation here is going to come and
i think it might be
kind of soon this move h3 i actually
remember looking at h3 back in the day
but let's see exactly where they go with
the theoretical duel
on that note alejandro do you have any
um
i don't know exactly how to put it uh
compunctions uh
about
playing stuff that you and fabi uh
looked at like you don't want to reveal
fabby's analysis but now the match is
over
you come up with some great novelties
did you get a chance to use them or were
you reluctant to use them i don't play
chess that much that's what it comes
down to i don't have the opportunity to
be using a lot of those novelties but
even if i did i don't i try not to go
into variations where favi and i looked
at something and also not just favi but
any of the students that i work with
including my university students they're
strong 2600 players and when they play
against elite in elite events like the
world cup and the sync field cup i don't
use their repertoire and i don't use
their files but that being said i think
that after two years most of those files
are just
right right right right gloves they're
completely obsolete new engines come in
there
they put so many holes into these
variations that it has to be redone
anyway so i think like a two three year
margin is more than good enough perfect
and for you peter too for example you
work with vladimir kramnik i've had
those uh those situations come up and uh
yeah there's there's definitely a time
lapse on these things because uh
as alejandro said like
used by such and such a date
i mean sometimes sometimes those things
are even sort of codified in the
agreement you uh you have with uh with
the person you work for
but even if it's not i think there's a
general understanding that you know some
ideas are more important than others but
i don't know within a year if it's not
used by then you have to assume that
it's now sort of public domain and
it will be discovered
yeah the boss the boss should not be
upset if you actually show it in an
important game and i mean
you probably shouldn't be playing it in
a random blitz tournament but sinful cop
is it's pretty a prestigious event
plenty plenty strong enough to be
showing you know your best stuff yeah
time to roll it out we have uh a begolia
buff uh
game between lavon and magnus like as we
came in you said they've passed 200
games in different formats whether
they're
classical the bogo bishop before check
and remember queen e7 was getting a very
uh nice workout back in the day as was
a5 yeah even c5 all of those things i i
associate much more with the bogo than
the move bishop takes you to bishop this
is a bit of a move
it's weird to be saying newfangled about
such a kind of a you know bare bones
system where black says yeah i will have
a solid position i'm not really trying
to to do anything anything anything
fancy i'm trading this bishop away to
you know make my castling faster but
right my structure is somewhat more
passive my bishop on c8 will be slightly
worse or maybe even not slightly worse
than the bishop on g3 or wherever it
lands right
honestly
my initial reaction every time i see
something like this is
this cannot possibly fully equalize
right
but then i saw off anderson back in the
day playing it as a religion and nobody
managing to defeat him yeah but but that
is exactly the point the point is if you
trust yourself to play these types of
slightly you know solid
uh
[Music]
i it's the second day in a row i cut
catch myself almost using the word
boring to describe a chess position
which i generally don't do but these are
not very exciting positions we have
right we have to be honest with
ourselves here
uh
and milos just knows what he's doing
there he's very very well versed in the
uh in the structures that arise from
here he is uh
it's become a bit of a kind of an inside
joke just how much he likes to play the
carlsbad from
whichever color right coming from
whichever opening yeah
and
uh because black has queen e7 i think is
uh as yasser has already indicated with
arrows is very much
aimed
at if allowed playing rook g8 perhaps
taking on c4 playing c5 just liquidating
everything along the gnc files and if
that happens black has no issues
whatsoever
the way to stop it would be to take on
d5
and and switch to a different structure
but
magnus is
seemingly like actively trying to get
the carl's ball in every in every game
yeah
well if you win him oh my gosh so
how happy are you with that yeah
for now roxy one play the other question
now is already
like how do we feel about gta xc4 and
then perhaps rock g8 and c5 or maybe
even the immediate c5 or do we want to
play let's say rook g8 for now
and continue giving white the option of
switching to cars bugs you know it's
strange uh you you once you start
learning chess and learning at a class
level it's all about development you
know you bring out your pieces and
you're helping your opponent you go
bishop before check you trade the
bishops
so white wants to use his extra
development when you get into a position
like this you don't really want to play
details absolutely you want to see this
bishop move and then move again so i
like your rook d8
play just say okay i'm giving the
giving the ball to you i'm passing it to
you in your court
is the move c4c5
i'm glad i got it in first yeah
because it's i'm curious if you could
like there's definitely some positions
in which it will it will be
a space grabbing
non-ridiculous yeah right i don't know
if it's here necessarily uh it's been
played a couple of times by reasonably
strong players we have one game by
chandra sandy pan who is a very well
established indian grandmaster but it
seems to me that this may be slightly
off off point even the immediate b6
followed by a5 followed by
trading everything uh sims player this
is a rook d8c5 and bass grab yeah and
you were saying black can reply to it in
in two ways i think one is this which is
very concrete go a5
and then we try to take i mean if if you
play a3 which maybe it's not forced
but if you do play three i take on
before i take on c5 i play this basics i
guess to get rid of that bishop on c8
not waiting for me to move my bishop but
going
yeah and this feels like it shouldn't be
very much right we did gain some space
but a lot of pieces will come off the
board
and
generally i think these types of
positions end up being uh
manageable for black you don't love it
but you don't hate it either aleandro as
we discussed the subtle nuances of the
queen's gambit declined more action
excitement over on your end
let's take a look at the hans niemann
game here against shakira mahmud yarov
because i mentioned yesterday that hans
loves these crazy and balanced positions
and when i saw his matchup against
mehmed i thought these guys are gonna
have be in for a fight and in for a
fight we are going to be we had this
english with the four knights and yasser
you were mentioning yesterday in passing
you passed my boar at some point you
were shocked that the move e4 is
currently one of the best moves in this
position truly it truly is and a lot of
theory has developed from this position
and a lot of it is crazy let's take a
look how this game proceeded bishop c5
and the entire point of this setup for
white is to take on e5 in this position
take advantage of the fact that if you
take on e5 right away then you have to
move d4 regaining your piece and gaining
some space in the center what's the
downside black has this move bishop
before and after pawn takes e5 this
capture on e4 immediately puts pressure
on the knight on f3 on c3 sorry the main
line here is queen d4 but lately people
have been experimenting more and more
and more with the move queen f3 so queen
f3 is played in this position there are
several answers that black has tried
here d5 is one of them queen h4 is the
computer suggestion but definitely in
the main line knight takes c3
pawn takes c3 and now bishop a5 there's
also been bishop e7 that has been tried
uh carlson caruana from last a couple of
years ago was in this position so bishop
a5 we're going to follow that game
bishop f4 played castle and now long
castle so you can immediately see that
this game is going to be crazy why
because both sides are castled in
different directions this pawn structure
on the queen side is terrible it's
ruined but what does white have in
return this powerful pawn on e5 it's
binding black you can't play d6 and
easily develop your queen side so it's
difficult to bring all of your pieces
out and what does white also have this
bishop coming to d3 and imagine a quick
attack on the king side if i force you
to play g6 via bishop d3 queen e4 i
might be able to play h4 h5 and rip you
apart on the king side very quickly so
what does my met do he plays first to
move queen e7 threatening this invasion
with the move queen a3 check of course
you cannot accept that king has to come
to b2 and we have the move rook b8 this
has all been played before in that
affirmation game between carlson and
caruana rook v8 preparing the move b5
which might be a sacrifice and very
quickly hans demon
replies with the main move queen e3 this
was not played in carlson corona but it
was played in a certain game between
nepomniacci and aronian of 2019 so we're
still following theory that game went
with the immediate b5 the move bishop b6
hitting the queen is also possible this
one is gonna be a wild one
i've got so many questions alejandro
this is an amazing donnie brooke i mean
i keep
well i'll keep i've lectured you know
protect your king at all times you know
don't leave your chin white egg open
exposed i look at that king on b2
um
uh peter and what can i say modern chess
yes what is this
you
obviously heavily influenced by
by engines and working with engines
right but if you look at it from the
other side if you give white a couple of
tempe here if i get to play let's say
bishop d3 followed by perhaps bishop g5
f6
i will be giving mate on the other side
of the board as well reasonably quickly
um okay and the bishop on c8 is not
really participating that's
which is why generally black plays b7 b5
here as quickly as possible just to
start something on on the queen side
bishop b6 yes of course is also playable
but i'm guessing the queen goes to h3 or
g3 yeah and
reinforces ideas of uh generating some
activity on the king's side in the
meantime the bishop on b6 stops your b5
and b5 uh okay jan played c5 in that
game in the game against levon here
but i'm sure there's a reason eight
games played in this position queen help
is out uh
too early in the afternoon it's the
obvious bishop a6
how did you miss that
bishop a6 yeah the pro the point is that
if you take on a6k8 just now wins the
queen rook it doesn't quite win the
queen i mean you do play queen b7 and it
escapes if you really want to punish
this
you start with the move queen c5
oh
it threatens queen takes f2 check
uh-huh and it also increases the
strength of the mover k8 in many
situations now
again engine chess right right b4 also
comes extremely strongly and if moment
is thinking in this position right it's
a tall ask
b5 queen takes a human
bishop a6 bishop a6 now to be fair this
is also probably fine for black to play
bishop b6 give up the rook and trap the
queen this way you do get two rooks but
again your king is pretty weak uh so not
necessarily an advantage here for white
actually the angels prefer taking the
bishop rather than the rook just so that
you remove some of the activity from
black's pieces but after queen e3 b5 is
certainly the most challenging move
let's try to continue that game that you
guys were mentioning between jan and
levon c5 b4 and you mentioned c4 in this
position now of course this has been
reached several times considering these
strong ratings of everybody that i see
in this list and considering that i
don't recognize anyone it must be a
correspondence
correspondence database a set of games
which is cool because that means that
engines are looking at this position and
a hundred percent of the games go with
the obvious move
b3 you gotta somehow shed this pawn
start getting some activity now this one
you can kind of understand because after
pawn takes b3 you do have bishop before
capturing that pawn on c5 opening dark
square avenues towards the king is it
over it's far from over the games
continue here there's going to be a lot
of theory most people that have reached
this position actually prefer the move
a3 so that the bishop doesn't go to b4
and you use this black pawn like a
shield we know this from a lot of games
in the past where instead of capturing
the pawn you just leave it there so that
the old pawn blocks the rook attack on
the king this was going to be fun queen
e3 the only thing i'm a little worried
about shaq is that he's burning through
some time in a position where i'm sure
hans has analyzed way way way more deep
than this position absolutely but i feel
kind of proud of myself peter i think i
got like
50
of that understanding including the move
a3 at the end and i'm a pawn grabber too
so
uh wow
uh a crazy crazy game has to be haunts
to be very happy about uh
the crap on the board no specifically
about the fact that the reply has not
has not come already right because this
is definitely a position where you would
like to be the side that knows versus
the side that doesn't exactly and just
that whole
basic
start stunningly beautiful move yeah
exactly okay cool and what else have you
been keeping an eye on too
um peter well uh magnus actually and
yeah i'm very happy about the catalan
let's let's take that okay let's go with
the cabinet because uh
so it was the open catalan with d5 takes
e4 a6 a6 and not c5 as uh as ali played
in the early years which promises us a
much sharper position
a6 castles knight c6 and here uh quincy
two is a i assume some kind of a
newfangled way to play this mission
because i think people used to play uh
there are basically two approaches here
one is e3 followed by perhaps even
knight f2 g2 to win the c4 pawn back
right which is i think quite topical and
there are some very sharp positions
potentially arising from there or you
could play knight c3 and then e2 e4 and
sort of just completely ignore the
opponent's e4 exists and go for central
compensation there is like duns and i
think that's through b8 is the main move
right generally speaking something like
this yeah and
ignoring the pawn lines for the time
being just pretending that we're not
down upon and we uh central control
gives us enough but uh jan goes with the
box number three here
saying being being done one pawn is not
enough let's let's be done too okay uh
take stakes and here in knight g2 uh the
poland c4 will uh will fall of course
and uh
theresa does i think a logical thing of
including c3 b takes c3 here to at least
close down the c file a little bit
exactly and also provide provide himself
with a reasonably safe square on c5 it's
not that safe but i think it's much
better than it would have been if we
didn't include c3 b take c3 agreed and
jan appears to be thinking here as far
as far as i can tell
this position cannot possibly be a new
one for him i think even i have seen
this i haven't analyzed this but i have
seen this and for somebody who is very
seriously playing the catalan these days
with the white pieces this cannot be a
surprise
i'm guessing he is trying to figure out
exactly the move orders there were some
recent games in this line i think icaru
played this i can see it on your screen
i remember that game he played it
against uh
uh janis papayano uh in degree
there was there was a team tournament or
maybe a club tournament of some sort
okay euro cup i think right yeah that
was yeah there was euro teams yeah
uh no your clubs not your not your teams
and uh white does have a number of
reasonably logical ways to make a pretty
safe draw here
uh which is something that jan will be
interested not one jordan
but
yeah you can start with rugby one
sometimes they play knight e4 here
either immediately or a bit later just
to
if you like you measure would be one
let's say b7 i don't think black cares
about the the bb7 very much and now we
go 94 with the point being if you take
we take with the bishop and we say
castle yeah castling is not as
comfortable for black here as you would
like we're gonna pick up some tempe
against you yeah but uh
black obviously is reasonably safe if
you do end up taking on b7 a lot of your
initiative disappears because people the
pieces get traded off the bishop on c8
very importantly gets traded off which
is a very poor piece and you get it
traded for a very nice bishop on e4
let's say yeah castles or queens 26
first and then castles i like my queen
on c6 here
so the margins are
i think reasonably wide here for black i
don't think this is as risky as some of
the other gambit type
positions in the catalan but you still
of course need to know what you're doing
now rook b1 uh you mentioned earlier e2
e4 that doesn't look like it's ever
going to be no
these kinds of positions we're not
playing
anything about knight b3 trying to kick
the i was thinking about that as well
yeah i was wondering specifically where
does the queen go right i suppose
h5 is one way yeah
we can also provoke it to e4 here
perhaps i don't know if it's any good
but there is some reason to play queen
f5
and ask you to play four so that your
bishop on g2 becomes a bit blunted good
point but it's a i mean generally
speaking provoking white
to occupy the center a bit better it's
not going to be always such a great idea
exactly exactly uh back over to you uh
alejandro this is a very interesting
catalan but again a little bit slow
development any action action oh yeah we
have action let's go to that one we're
going to go back to this game between
favi and linear we left it off in this
particular position
and five played the move g4 now this is
an idea that we had analyzed in the
world championship match we thought it
wasn't so directly against the king if
you wanted to get to the king there were
better ways to do so but it was annoying
for the knight on f6 it was very
difficult for the knight to find a good
square because most of the time you were
trying to play the move d5 to take
control of the center and the moment
that happened g5 came with great effect
unless you had knight e4 available your
position could crumble pretty quickly
now what happened in the game queen a5 a
completely different approach instead of
playing d5 the queen immediately targets
stuff on the queen side for the moment
the pawn on a2 is hanging there's two
very different ways to do the defense on
a2 king b1 and a3 and they're completely
different
in the in how the game develops
afterwards if i chose the move a3 d5 you
can see there's no longer any games in
the database but i remember because i
was part of the team that we analyzed a
lot of these structures very in very
similar situations that it required a
lot of deep theory because positions
could be forcing in this position after
d5 if you play g594 is very strong but
five instead chooses to move c4 it's a
very very well timed break this capture
on d2 and after bishop takes d2 is far
from equal for black this pressure on d5
is annoying g5 is going to be annoying
at some point kicking out the knight if
you go to e4 immediately then you just
put the bishop back on e3 and again the
pawn on d5 is not so easy to defend you
could play bishop e6 but i will leave
this tension up because the knight on e4
doesn't have another defender so i'll
just develop my rook either to e1 the
computer says g1 but i remember it's e1
and
black's position is not very safe
instead lanier plays the move queen a4
certainly he is still within his
preparation and fabi plays this fabulous
move c3 gives up the pawn on c4 with the
tempo just so that he can keep this
bishop on the diagonal haki instead
played the move c takes d5 then it would
have been linear that puts his pawn on
c4 and notice how this starts to become
dangerous this bishop suddenly opens to
the a3 square and you might be thinking
of a sacrifice or just winning the game
with bishop takes a3 so black is
actually in control in this position c3
is the recommendation of the computer
certainly lanier had to have seen this
position and we know because of the time
usage by both sides that they're both
still somehow in their book after d
takes c4 bishop c2 queen a6 actually
came rather quickly now when favi plays
his book he plays it instantly when
lanier plays his book he still takes a
couple of minutes to research exactly in
the position and try to remember what he
needed to do probably fabi had this on
his computer screen this morning queen
a6 g5 plate knight h5 and knight e5
still favi has not burned a single
minute of the on the clock actually has
four minutes extra from where he started
and lanier is finally thinking a little
bit he spent a couple of minutes in this
move and you know that he's going to be
out of book the moment that those two
minutes turn into 20 but until then we
might we must assume that this he has
seen this position before the computer
says it's equal of course
g6 is one move just to stifle this
bishop's diagonal but a more logical
approach would be a move like bishop e6
what does white have in return for the
pawn he has a lot of control over the
center he has better development the
spawn of c4 is rather weak and this
knight on h5 is offside that being said
there are no clear targets in the
position yes there's a lot of pressure
on the king side but what exactly you're
going to be threatening the pawn on h7
is already defended the pawn on f7 is
already defended and can you defend it
again with the move bishop e6 you're not
really going to play g6 and sacrifice
everybody there f45 is also difficult to
achieve but it might be a possibility
except especially after bishop e6 so a
dynamic game linear with an extra pawn
fabiano with the initiative and
certainly with a lot of knowledge of
what to do exactly in this position
wow super double edged peter uh you just
need your reaction to this pond
sacrifice by uh fabi you feel it doesn't
you you feel good for white
well
if i didn't know anything like if i
couldn't see the clock situation if i
didn't know the names below the screen
you know
and you didn't have that chess engine in
the background
my my initial reaction here is that
honestly it doesn't look that horrible
for black it looks like uh as alejandra
was saying we developed the bishop to e6
to stop you know
what has happened right
any kind of potential shenanigans here
connected with the f7 pawn
if white goes f2 f4 which i think is
definitely part of the plan here at
least we can stop with g76 we can also
stop it with knight g3 f5 because f4 has
this major drawback of allowing the h5
knight back into the game right rook 88
is coming rather quickly uh which will
allow black perhaps to trade some stuff
off the board
this doesn't look horrible i understand
there is definitely compensation and you
know once we play g76 the knight from e5
can go to g4 and start being a bit
menacing there on the king's side
exactly should i and should i toss in a
move like queenie e2 therefore it's
possible yeah i don't know if it's quick
enough but it's definitely a
consideration something like this okay
but
it seems solid to me it seems like uh we
haven't gotten as much as we normally
would have liked to uh to get on the
king's side but obviously fabi is you
know still on 93 minutes from 90
starting right
so
my opinions here are largely irrelevant
but but don't forget that black actually
is a pawn up don't even uh consider
giving him the two moves
before
our king could get zach peter this is
this is i mean
in my opinion fabi will have to produce
the goods very very quickly you you have
to play extremely energetically here
with white otherwise black stabilize and
as you mentioned if you give black time
to play v5 before
your attack on the king side will will
fade into
insignificance completely and
you'll have to start defending very
double-edged by the way just want to go
back to the hans niemann versus
game because
after some time by the way it didn't
come
how much time i'm not quite oh only only
15 minutes now okay not as much as no b5
none of them no b5 and no no bishop b6
okay a very very quiet move compared to
uh some of the others giving white time
perhaps to play bishop d3 if you want to
which i think would you know it would
seem to be the most logical move i don't
think we have something to be said for
but g5 queen c5 maybe i don't know if
yeah one of the benefits of having maybe
the b6 yeah maybe that's the point so
all right let's go for the bishop d3
seems logical uh just bringing more
stuff into play
and if we try to play it slowly uh isn't
white gonna
yeah you produce threats yeah you play
g6 i still am not entirely sure how
we're getting mated here but black
hasn't started anything on the green
side yet
so
it's even though the king
yeah it's very looks somehow vulnerable
it's not yeah you give white
two more moves here you just get mated
so you kind of want to play b6b5
i wonder if
somehow uh shakrir was not entirely
aware of the you know the state of
modern theory here completely because b6
does look like a move of a man who
perhaps has not looked at this very
deeply and actually perhaps just got
confused why b5 queen takes a seven
wasn't winning yes exactly
uh looks like a pretty lame novelty this
move b7 b6 uh
alejandra it doesn't that doesn't feel
like shaq's got his uh finger on the
pulse of the position well the engines
don't like it but it's not such a
horrible move this is a position where i
expected that any small mistake might be
heavily punished because of the
sharpness of the position the computers
do say why it's already better how
h4 just go forward rook h3 rook g3 is
one possibility h5 is a possibility this
bishop d3 move that you guys are saying
is also a good move but it doesn't
create all of the threats that you would
think bishop b7 is logical because of
the move that you just played in my
opinion it's not so logical to play rook
b8 and b6 but
that's what shaq is probably going to do
the engines think that here the move
bishop c2 is very clever first of all
queen d3 is a double attack
and second you're actually removing
yourself from perpetuals and you're like
what perpetuals well i was playing
around with the engine a little bit here
and after bishop v7 i was wondering why
doesn't this just win right and
apparently after f6 pawn takes f6 well
you can take on e3 which is apparently
not as bad as i thought for black
but also this move apparently is just a
draw
that's why you open the e file because
the moment you cross over to
um the e file here in this position with
queen b4 you get pinned with rookie
eight so this somehow draws the game
immediately and
it just shows that black actually still
has a lot of resources despite the fact
that he played a move that as you said
yasser it's a little on the slow side
it's kind of lame h4 in this position
makes a lot of sense in in my view of
course after h4 the engines want to go
b5 but
things that are not going to happen and
bishop d3 is of course what i think is
the more human move yeah
thanks for the charcoal by the way yes i
was going to say yeah
we clearly are you know suffering here
from
we're actively trying to you know kind
of
replace this like move this game away
from our field of vision no it's there
we have to see it we have to mention
that these guys are playing come on
let's go guys
there's also one more game which we
haven't mentioned at all uh uh
after the announcement of the pairings
the game where mvl is white against
wesley so let's do it yeah we're just
going to get straight to move 19. i'm
not going to this is a berlin man game i
assume most of you our dear viewers know
how the berlin endgame appears on the
board
uh of the three of us perhaps alejandro
has some idea of what the current state
of the opening is i lay absolutely no
claim to knowing anything about this i
mean my my knowledge of the berlin
endgame is as follows and thankfully
nobody with white tests black on the
berlin end game so i don't have to learn
it
that is the current state of my theory
on it uh but uh luckily for us
you know with the movie 5v6 which which
just has been played on the board this
is the situation you can you can finally
use common sense
black will take on e6 the question is
how you take 186 i think generally black
likes in these types of positions to get
as much stuff off the board as possible
let's do it so i wouldn't be surprised
if wesley actually takes with the bishop
and then maybe even the rook
uh and then white takes on e6 takes on
c7 and this is actually i was about to
say but it's it's a straight
transposition to a game which i have
very very painful memories of
uh really i i knew it looked similar but
i didn't know it was the exact same
position this is a game from 2012
uh a game between alexander grieschuk on
the white side and sir game of thrones
on the black side and the reason i have
painful memories of it is that it was i
believe round six of the european club
cup
and sergey masterson was playing for uh
for my club from st petersburg we were
on five out of five until that match
okay and we drew five games and sergey
did not hold this end game against sasha
meaning that we lost we lost that match
and then we won uh in the last round but
the very very strong azerbaijani team
won with a massive score in the last
round and they overtook us on tie breaks
so
in some way you know and i don't like
it's ridiculous to blame sergey for the
entirety of the thing but
we will because but we still will yeah
exactly uh
the basically that one loss cost us a
very very uh clear
clear win in the european club cup yeah
at first sight it feels minimal but
since you said such a such a strong
player or sergey losing this ending goes
to show there is some dangers here you
like if if you move the pawn back from
g5 to g6
then i think you're a happy camper i
think in instant instantly you say yes
it's still unpleasant but i'm probably
not going to lose it wow because
because i i think it just becomes almost
impossible to generate a passer on the
king's side so just to put that in
perspective for our viewers for a second
uh we get into the same uh and so sergey
didn't even play rook g8 in this
position because he was very worried he
will lose this bishop ending exactly
because now what you're saying is at a
certain moment we'll be able to play f4
we'll get a pass on the king side
thanks to the fact the pawn is on g5 we
put it back on g6 and maybe it's easier
no this bishop ending becomes just dead
drawn if it's on g6 i'm pretty sure
there's just no winning chances so yeah
this is this is something i've seen
before and
i'm pretty sure it's holdable with
precise play but it's also not very much
fun exactly and it's very very possible
to lose this as as is evidenced by by
the fact that it had been lost which
begs the question why then would wesley
be so
willing to
maybe maybe i can uh improve the
idea and
maybe just keep this in the bands for a
moment and play g5 it might become a
weakness though yeah you you could do
that and bishop takes it we'll see in a
moment because where did you take with
the bishop on e6 i'm pretty sure the
knight takes c6 will happen
leaving the bishop alive seems uh
illogical to me and then we will see
what wesley prefers four rooks or two
i'm just uh suggesting that
i'm a bit worried like in this position
like i take take and i play i don't know
rookie four
and then i started this is that i
started immediately hinting that like
rogue gg4 might be i i was gonna have to
get rid of that one yeah that's the
second round fake stakes
i'm assuming i recapture with the king
first years drinking h2
i don't know how happy you are happy
i'm definitely not happy i don't have
bishop h4 but it might be losing to f3
right
i feel i'm on the back foot and i i'm a
long long way from equalizing well we'll
keep that one in our back pockets and
again a game that's kind of slipped away
from us a bit lavon versus magnus let's
just actually did something that we
thought he might not be doing so he is
like very concentrated on just
equalizing today
abundance the hope of playing the
carlsbad today and for winning a tempo
back with rook d8 or something like that
but rather going into a queen's gambit
accepted kind of ending
where
where it's four versus four on the
king's side two versus two on the queens
and these types of positions are of
course if black finishes development
there's never anything at all for white
like if you if you imagine black playing
bishop d7 e8 rook ac8 like you're you're
completely completely fine due to the
absolute symmetry and very very solid
structure
one plan to perhaps interrupt that would
be to try to push for very very quick
e45 okay
and that's it
well the other thing again i'm looking
at the position i've got my bishop on
cb4 i've got my rook on c1 bishop b5 i'm
trying to exploit the openc file i don't
know exactly
just stops it so solidly yeah okay and
then maybe knight a4 c5 or something
like e4 c5 yeah
let me try another
so like if you do oblige me uh
for whatever reasons doing something
like this even here let's say go queen
is seven exactly
exactly
eight i'm not that unhappy
i think i think b7 is not a weakness
it's just a like a minor inconvenience
that i have to cover it but i will cover
it
right i'm trying yeah but bishop e8 27
like they i i feel like i
like like
with each reduction of every uh piece uh
my my advantage keeps abbing being away
um
wow okay we'll keep an eye on this and
back over to you
uh
alejandro what do you have for us i'll
let you know that what has happened in
this game the engine is rather approved
or black
they don't see a good way to maintaining
a lot of pressure yes it's a little bit
of an advantage to have this bishop on
c8 it's locked in for white
but what are you going to do with it
this planets with e4 they're not really
working out this position despite the
fact that it hasn't been reached many
times looks perfectly playable for the
black side i'm wondering how levon is
going to put any real pressure today and
again it's this way that magnus has of
playing where he's not playing this main
line openings he's not playing what he
considers to be the most harmful ideas
he came in yesterday he said that this
variation that he played against nepal
was harmless clearly it wasn't harmless
because he bit yande bomyachi in it so
he has these ideas that go beyond the
exact uh popularity or mentions by the
engine at this moment it's very
difficult to find a plan that really
preserves much for white the engine is
already only giving like 0.2 for the
wide position which is it's not very
much let's go around the horn a little
bit i wanted to just point out that in
this position uh there is no choice for
black knight takes e6 you have to take
with the rook if you take with the pawn
a huge advantage for the wide side
according to the engines you also have
to take with the bishop i just want to
point out that if you took with the pawn
yes bishop takes c7 immediately strong
but the move knight f3 is even stronger
very difficult to deal with knight e5
this bishop on d7 is just entombed by
these pawns on c6 and e6 meanwhile hans
demon he played bishop d3 mehmed did not
play bishop b7 he continues playing
unpredictable moves currently play the
move queen e6 it does make sense in the
because you are protecting some squares
on the king side the move bishop g5
won't hit the queen anymore and i
imagine that he wants to put the bishop
on a6 and target the weakness on c4 i
say i imagine because i'm not really
sure about that plan you always have
queen e4 attacking the pawn on h7 back
so we'll see what happens in this
position already the engines are giving
a large advantage to hans again with its
favorite move h4 so we'll see if hans
finally
clamps down on that idea in the game
between alireza and uh ferugia sorry
between jan and eli reza rook b1 was
played after a significant uh by a thing
by jan and alariz is just stuck he has
not played a since the game that you
guys had mentioned between nakamura with
the black pieces and papaya now with
white did follow with the move queen h5
immediately so we're going to let
already think on this one because well
he is in a position where he doesn't
usually play which is then the defensive
butt up a pawn all right thank you for
that alejandro turning for attention
second to the game of fobby versus
lanier a very consequent decision
uh fabi took uh peter
we talked about the pluses and minuses
of the move f2f4 f4 well
the move obviously has a huge threat f4
f5 and we get a great initiative the
problem is
that uh it does give up the g3
control of the g3 square and the knight
could easily land back on a pretty good
defensive square of fight take us
through the thought processes of this
i would like like this is one of the
positions
those types of positions where uh like
my my ideal course of action here would
be as a commentator if i could just shut
up for five minutes
and try to understand why this is
supposed to be good for white because my
initial reaction is once this knight
gets to a five it gets supported by g76
if need be but you actually have to
provoke me to play g6 right it's quite
safe on a safe on f5 as is let's say
you're 195. i i'm not voluntarily
playing g6 in any case right and if
there's no threat like i'm starting to
ask myself why am i not just playing b7
b5 b5 before and saying uh
my victory yeah
i mean if if we successfully make white
think about the queen side yes it's half
it's half the battle already yeah the
battle won yeah and
it's it's very confusing i understand
fabi is not bluffing here fabi has some
idea but
for me i'm i'm struggling yeah i i'm me
too i'm i'm i'm trying to find some
trickies uh utilizing the knight on e5
it's there keep trying keep trying hey
look at that look we're being encouraged
peter yeah i mean and alejandro is a
tough task it doesn't win
some sort of bishop c5 on queen d5
that's exactly it he told me to look for
it
he told me to look for it that's the
problem when you're in a tournament game
nobody comes up to you and taps you on
the shoulder
and says hey peter you got a combination
actually that's kind of a pretty one
actually it's cute yeah it's cute but i
was prompted yes if precisely it prompts
me i suddenly become a much stronger
player
i still remember this game
from
zagreb uh between
sergey kariyaki and it was this one move
went it was just one move sergey came in
and they said sergey
show was a good position show is a good
move and he went
oh yeah and that's it oh
uh oh
okay oh
uh knight f5 bishop c5 okay we're not
forced to go knight to five perhaps
maybe we could uh but then queen f2
bishop takes c5 is an actual no combos
it's very straightforward did we did we
uh
make a judgment on that final position
by the way i mean did we say oh what a
wonderful combination and white's got a
great advantage well f7 is very
important so we're giving up the bishop
on c5 i'm pretty sure we're not giving
yes
correct so let's play
i don't care rookie seven uh yeah
rookies yeah maybe perhaps rookie seven
queen c5 okay no i've landed a rook
there right okay queen oh sorry
yeah yeah yeah me too i did the same
thing for the audience right yes of
course uh rookie seven
uh puzzle rush tactics everybody uh yeah
they've got a back rank made issue that
would be quite painful yeah ouch
okay so
maybe it's just that we don't have a
good condition yeah but if we play
bishop e6 we we're also abandoning the
the most attractive diagonal this bishop
has and maybe you can be kind of yeah
maybe you can be kind of bold and play
bishop i got a knife
how about this how about this man i
guess i mean you're forcing me to play
rook d2 but i'm not that unhappy
but i'm so proud of myself i got a
thread of checkmate in one honey don't
you feel ashamed that you've uh
no i don't know and in the meantime
is on the board just to update our
viewers we're actually we're covering
something which could become extremely
relevant very much so uh and here we are
nike by the way rook e1 uh
um yeah if you if you don't move the
knight away from from uh g3 f2 bishop
takes c5 is a very straightforward very
obvious threat right needs to be
addressed yeah
but peter in that case g7 g6 okay again
a move that that kind of relaxed but if
i get you to play queen f2 bishop c5 i
like this one those this i suddenly very
much like for white in particular if the
dark bishops come off like knight g4
knight f6 will start becoming a major
major issue if there's no bishop no more
i completely agree
no this is very very valuable that that
that turned south
wow
a fun fun fun uh position uh i must say
knight g3 rookie one
on the board
well do you want the evaluation please
please i mean you know the evaluation
yeah we know that zero zero
of course let's take a look at some of
the lines that follow this variation
with bishop takes c5 bishop takes c5
bishop takes f5 bishop takes here queen
d5 now
believe it or not black's top three
moves are zero zero uh completely
different approaches one the greedy one
bishop f2 wow forces queen takes f7
knight takes f7 just doesn't work king
h8 and because knight g6 can be met with
either bishop or queen takes g6
defending
that rook on e8 those combinations don't
work the only move is to take on f5 and
bishop takes e1 is playable you can
either take on e1 or play knight f7
check but somehow white ends up with no
more than a perpetual at any point this
looks absolutely terrifying for the
blacks for black because knight f7
knight h6 might even be an idea that's
one way of doing so by the way we're
going straight into that because knight
fight bishop takes c5 already on the
board so let's continue after this this
queen d5 there's other ways of playing
one is to play queen e6 queen takes c5
is absolutely forced and you can just
chase the queen away or you can even
take on h3 this is the most computer
move in the history of computer moves
you take this useless pawn opening up
the h file for the rook and giving up a
free tempo but the engine says hey it's
a pawn
and the last one is the one that you
mentioned rook f8 queen takes c5 queen
a4 threatening checkmate here and
against rook d2 both rook d8 or rook a8
actually the computer is preferring rook
d8 a little bit more seems to keep
dynamic equality there the point
i was kind of hoping for white but then
i realized h3 is hanging the point is
we're forcing queen takes c4 by playing
rook again we're pretty much forcing the
same game with queen takes c4 queen
takes e4 and then in the end we win it
back on h3 take stakes you give a check
just because it's precise it doesn't
matter where the king goes up or down
you take on h3 and the engines think
it's zero zero it's not bad for black
yeah yeah bishop against knight in an
open in an open end game yeah shouldn't
be shouldn't be bad peter this is one of
the things
and i really do want to mean to share
this with the audience that i think that
computers
have had a huge impact is that they've
shown us
their positions that we might have
thought that were bad they've shown us
ways that we can defend them and in this
case
three
three uh alternatives for blacks in
black including bishop f2 including
queen e6 that's a remarkable yeah part
of it i think
also one other thing i wanted to mention
is that
you become very accustomed to
sort of investigating further because
you know there will be answers available
to you in a form like
it's very tempting or it would have been
very tempting when i was a kid to just
like get here 93 rook he one realizes
tactic exists you know put this infinity
sign right and clear
in your notebook right and you know move
on to the next variation but these days
these days you uh you get very
accustomed to and you keep digging
deeper and deeper and deeper falling and
also as you say
you you see so often a somewhat
promising position uh you get there and
you think i must be just a bit a little
bit better here and then you investigate
and you realize there's not one but a
bunch of solutions for your opponent
here which all hold uh and that and that
also changes your perception of you know
sort of the the uh the edges available
or like lag thereof perhaps yeah yeah
and one of the things i grew up of
course with bobby fischer and we
we praised his accuracy to the sky bobby
made these uh remarkable
the good moves and we kind of wrongfully
came to this idea that each move each
position each position possessed one
great move and you're always looking for
the best move the computer's kind of
dissuaded us of that yeah i think that
that notion i mean there will of course
still be positions where there is one
solution but of course uh but yeah
these days very very often you see like
you you find a promising idea and then
you you start looking at it more closely
and you realize it's still a promising
idea in human terms because if you if
you're the first one to show it over the
board your opponent will will perhaps
struggle yeah but a bunch of solutions
probably presents itself if you if you
investigate properly exactly and of
course at
any moment throughout our show
we are of course social media
we love your
comments and questions to ourselves and
uh
um
uh send your uh tweets to
you you can you can definitely you can
definitely ask us questions uh uh use we
know all we tell very little likely
yeah you can you can tweet at us at uh
stl chess club or uh
all the chats are being being monitored
right not by us because they're but
anastasia yeah but uh there are there
are people out there who are very very
valiantly keeping track of things being
said truly that uh turning our attention
to uh ian and ali reza for just a moment
seems like we got in exactly the moves
that you have mentioned peter in fact
both in both cases both rook b1
different but yeah this is still the uh
than the camera papaya now game as
alejandra mentioned uh hikaru played
queen h5 here there are other moves
available as well i'm a bit curious that
already is thinking for so long because
this is
this is still a known position i think
alireza is below an hour now and he's
been thinking for almost 15 minutes and
yang hasn't really spent any time
any time yet very good
we'll see what transpires afterwards but
for now i think we will take a break but
tell us about qbt first yeah let's take
a look uh let's take a look at today's
featured now again are we giving uh
friends and family discount on this one
like five percent potentially
potentially this is a simple cup jacket
uh it's 100 polyester zip up jacket with
a sink fill cup logo as you can see
there uh on the front and the saintliest
chess club logon on the back
uh they're available
for in both men's and women's fashion
and as it is everything else on the show
it's available at
cubaticstl.com so to take to take a look
and as we go to break we have some
interviews that anastasia has made we
hope you enjoy it we'll see you on the
other side of our break stay tuned
so here we are with american rapper
logic with such a logical chess name how
happened
yeah that's uh i probably should have
shaved before this interview
yeah but i mean when i heard the i mean
that you're here i mean it's it's a very
big
honor for our events to have you here so
welcome to single hub how was it going
did you like it um yeah i absolutely
loved it here it was amazing i'm sorry
for the sound in the background i've
always wanted to come here and my good
friend joe bruin he invited me today him
and uh and danny wrench and yeah i got
to see some of the greatest players ever
to do it
in their element so yeah yeah and who's
your actual favorite player who am i
rooting for
i mean we all love magnus right
but also
i don't know man ollie's great and you
gotta love bobby so it's like those
three like i want to see what happens i
don't know i know that's like a weird
answer but i love magnus but i also love
those other guys too so that's for sure
how was the playing call i mean did you
enjoy watching the game so close
yeah that was really
amazing and then even beforehand being
able to like play a couple games myself
um here at chess club it was really
special actually it doesn't happen every
day that you i mean you play with the
hockey player chess i mean robert thomas
was here as well yeah and how how was it
won at the end he was a real gentleman
and um but i took them two games
that's cool i know that you are going to
have a concert i think today so
i looking forward
yes i can't wait for the show tonight i
think it's going to be amazing thousands
of people are going to be there and
we're going to have a blast yeah thank
you so much will you invite us to the
players of course everybody can come
thank you all the best of luck on the
show thank you very much
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to round two of the
sinkhole cup all five games are still
very much in progress plenty of action
today as it will be the case every day i
assume here
no reason not to assume that right i
love the variety of uh today's games in
fact peter
let's take a look at uh what's going on
here first of all are the pairings of
round two we as we mentioned we've got
good games in each and every one of them
absolutely
the the arguably the game of the round
the one that is the longest-standing
rivalry among the pairings today the one
between lebanon and magnus carlson is
probably the quietest position of the
round so far right there is still there
is still something to play there but
uh magnus appears to have completely
equalized everything else is very much
uh up in the air though with with some
very very sharp positions but let's talk
about this uh for the moment what a
clash yeah this is a very very well
known uh fight at some point i think
both of them were uh
you know
heirs apparent to the throne so to speak
around 20 2012 2011
the london candidates in particular i
think was a tournament in which both of
them were considered very very uh
obvious pre-tournament favorites
uh and one of them did end up winning
that tournament one had a very very nice
first half indeed
definitely uh and
what that uh head-to-head clash uh just
showed was their um
classical matchups in fact they probably
played upwards of 200 tournament games
when you include their rapid and blitz
as well so those two players live on and
magnus certainly have a a measure of one
another i want to i think a very very
healthy amount of respect for each other
i think it always is like the way magnus
approaches those games in particular
like if we watch what he's doing today
with the black pieces
uh there's absolutely no hanky-panky of
any sort he's right he's playing to
equalize he knows that in a position
like this and you always kind of
hesitate to say that magnus will never
have winning chances in the game because
we've seen him win all kinds of
positions right but this one this one is
about as
solid but never really ever better for
black as you can get i think these days
but he's i think very safely e3 queen a5
it's interesting that he chose the a5
square but i guess it's it's played with
a sort of one eye on the 45 plan which i
continue to maintain is the only way
white can get anywhere at all here
you're saying that between the choices
of moving your queen to get out of the
discovery you have a5 and potentially
no a5 and h5 are similar there's also e7
and of course e7 yes exactly and e7
is i think in terms of stopping e45 it's
maybe the
uh the least consequential of the the
choices black has because it really
relinquishes all control over the
central uh central squares and perhaps
e34 can be played let's take a look at
the 34 right here because i understand
that
i think the engines just say that white
is already
not better whatever you do right but i'm
curious how would you reply here with
black uh my knee jerk response would be
knight g4 i would want to
in particular uh control oops sorry i
got my
my circles and arrows wrong in
particular i would want to control these
two squares and i would want to play
knight g40 so that i could one day dream
to play dream of playing exactly that
would be i think it's extremely logical
and i think it's once again it shows us
why the queen is on a5 right right
because with the queen on e7 i would
quite happily i think be playing e45
here but exactly
for example let's just go back to queen
e7
and here the timing would be all
together
wrong this might just be bad oops might
just be horrible for black exactly which
is why the queen stays on the fifth rank
and levon has made a very very uh
not on my radar yeah like it wouldn't be
in my top 10 moves in this position
exactly
i am not sure yes again guess again
guess again queen e2
c4 from the mind of levon oroni and as
we were on our break
all three of us were discussing
this whole bogo indian and how
rather confused we were because of
anderson had been playing the stuff in
the 80s you're just trading off one
piece but helping this opponent and
nobody could beat him
and here's magnus in the computer saying
zero zero zero yeah peter remarkable
yeah it feels like you have to be uh
very very precise with your move orders
because as i mentioned you know we had
the discussion that for the first time
today during uh during the round at
around move seven
and after e3 between seven i you know we
we thought
this has to be at least a little bit
better for white to play precisely and
then like four moves later
it does seem like completely equal so
perhaps levon made one slightly
inaccurate somewhere and it's all gone
right now i'm going to be very unfair to
you peter because as you said queen in
c4 was not even on your radar no idea
help us out i'm giving up this knight e4
idea that's that's the only explanation
like for example bishop d7 right i mean
94 yeah probably this is the the
explanation okay but even if you get
this you're not really
right exactly i mean
give me an indication of what you think
the advantage might be well if there is
if you could play bishop c2 here and
provoke g6 maybe you have some hopes
but the thing is queen h5 exists also
bishop e8 is not forced so perhaps you
can prevent it by playing something like
maybe queen beef could before rook c4
actually i don't mind provoking roxy f4
queen before queen is seven here just
bring it closer to the uh queen's king
side that you are
eventually going to have to defend and
if bishop c2 with the rook on c4 i could
be maybe even convinced the player i
started to feel like the queen c4
queenie for sally
does have a purpose but also i wanted to
mention something please uh if we go
back to the current position yeah
perhaps you know knowing that knight c34
is probably on
hawaii let's go 95.
okay that takes the game in a completely
different direction
i think the plan here is queen of four
because i think if you think only
tingling
i thought i woke up
good morning saint louis yes but then i
like 95 quite a lot by the way i'm being
told that ali raza has gone into a think
tank of over 30 minutes and it's not
what hurts it's more than half an hour
in a position which is still whoa
it's not very well known but the one
game that was played in this position is
quite high profile and uh
it was his choice to play six knight c6
so and what's the one game if i were to
continue from this position
yeah queen h5 is the movie that hikaro
played here okay looks logical and he
finally he finally does play
the commentator's curse i was just about
to play queen h5 when f5 appeared on the
board and uh is that still theory peter
no it's it's i think it was one of the
top two moves like finish five being one
and a five being the other where the top
two machine suggestions here well in
both cases what we're doing is blunting
the attack against h7 and prepping yeah
we wanted short castles
so f7 f5 kind of looks a little more
forcing actually now that i think about
it uh obviously the pawn on b7 can be
taken at any point but quite generally i
think in these types of positions would
very much like even if it costs them the
immediate opportunity to win back the
sacrificed
uh pawn
to preserve the disparity of
the very active bishop on let's say g2
here if we just play bishop g2 and steal
a rather passive bishop on c8 i don't
really like the idea of trading those
two guys if you'll excuse me for just a
second i love developing with the tempo
i wonder where the queen goes you know i
mean if i'm forcing the queen i don't i
don't care queen a3 queen a5 your choice
or even i think it might be i think it
might be quincy iv you might i think it
might be q4 because i think we don't
mind bishop d3 at all i think if we are
provoking this three we'll we'll put the
queen on c6 yeah i'm losing my touch if
you will with the partner b7 bishop e3
queen c4 and then once again we have a
choice between bishop takes b7 which i
think is pretty much nothing and
dropping it back to g2 and continuing
playing and you like the immediate
response okay
we'll keep an eye on this and uh turn it
over to alejandro and alejandro where's
the action a couple of updates in this
fascinating english that hans demon is
playing against mama dyarov
we did get to this position with the
move bishop d3 we mentioned queen e6 and
after something hans decided not to go
for this move h4 which was the engine's
recommendation instead put the move
queen g3 on the board which is a kg move
because i thought well yeah b5 is
possible as you can see the arrow by the
engine but i've already played b6 i
don't think you're playing b5
necessarily i was wondering what about
bishop b7 or bishop a6 immediately loses
to bishop g5 he immediately loses
according to the end loses yes loses
like plus five bishop f6 is coming it
starts sacrificing the exchange with f5
he takes f6 rook takes f6 says please
take my material just so i don't get
made it
instead
mamadiarov plays a very clever move to
move rookie 8 and that means that this
bishop is currently stuck defending the
pawn on e5 so you don't have the time to
do bishop g5 immediately now the move
rook he one is possible h4 is also
possible now funny move that i oh at
least i think is funny the engine's
second best move is the move a4
what
because you're preventing b5 right i
mean
that way you don't get some of your
pieces in play it's a funny move i don't
expect it i don't expect this to go this
way but rookie one i feel is very
logical i think this would be a very uh
normal way to play after queen g3 since
you are able to defend the pawn on e5
and now liberate the bishop on f4 the
edges think that with the difference of
the rooks now bishop a6 is playable um
but
and the bishop g5 doesn't win the game
immediately because b5 comes here with a
lot of tempe and now that the rook is
not on f8 somehow you have different
defensive resources but instead of
bishop a6 bishop g5 there's an extra
resource here for black for white now
that i brought my rook to e1 and is to
play the move rook e4 and then start
attacking on the king side i feel like
the bishop g5 itself is pretty dangerous
i'm gonna have to look at it with more
depth but even the move rookie four i
think starts an attack on the king side
that can be quite strong the engines
were not in love with the move queen g3
because of b5 or rookie 8 but i think
it's a rather logical way of playing
here for hans and i believe that he will
follow it up with the move rook he1 in
this position thank you for that one
thing one thing that's interesting to me
in this entire conversation is that we
we think i think understandably due to
his his age and uh
you know his pedigree as a as a modern
you know youngster who plays a lot
online and generally i don't
exactly know his coaching situation but
he appears to me
uh from from what little i know to be uh
to a large degree you know not
self-taught necessarily but uh you know
a bit of a lone wolf studying with
he's had a bunch of opportunities in
this game to play h4
which you know resisted each and every
one of them we think that this is you
know so much you know part of everyday
sort of chess parlance these days the
the moment h4 becomes a logical move in
any position you kind of make it
automatically these days because you
just assumed the machine would approve
and you very often will be correct yeah
but he's he's already passed up a couple
of uh very promising points to play h4
rook h3o g3 for instance right and uh
yeah
meaning that uh it's still not as deeply
ingrained in in players as we sometimes
like to to pretend
uh peter could i ask you a question that
i find a little bit vexing myself after
the move queen e6 right here
you know i'm looking at this bishop on
a5 and i'm saying you're out of the game
you're you're like the the worst bishop
i've ever seen the only way you're
getting into civilization is you're
going to play have it to play b5
so i'm going to play a really off uh
like look at my pawn structure and i'm
going to even make it worse
yeah i'm going to make it absolutely
worse queen h3 i'm going to force look i
mean it's abysmal puncher i can't even
believe i'm saying this
but at the moment you're playing a piece
down
you're yeah for the time being you're
gonna have to play b5 one eventually
yeah and and help mike you're gonna
you're gonna repair my pawn structure
and in the me i'm not saying that i'm
gonna checkmate you some beautiful way
or anything but isn't this playing on
one goal
i don't think so but it's definitely
playable which it normally wouldn't be
like with a bishop on basically any
other
non-attached player yeah
it might be a great square yeah if that
bishop is on any kind of other dark
square where it doesn't get taken
immediately right
black is black is instantly probably
winning not even agreed not agree better
between with the bishop specifically on
a5 i agree with you this looks playable
and i can't immediately find a way to
let's say solve all of our issues uh
tactically
but i don't think anybody plays great no
but i'm just saying you you you kind of
start to understand where i'm going here
absolutely there is a half open d file
there are moves like bishop f5 maybe
bishop c2 bishop a4
you could easily find yourself
you know playing a move like d6 and
hoping for some positions absolutely
yeah and it's it's a good it's a good
thing to show on the board here because
it's very very uh rarely that you will
be able to make a move like this
and not instantly be in
trouble exactly exactly so it's it's
good to to demonstrate this for for the
viewers just uh
as a kind of a
very very stark
uh focus on the bishop on a5 and the
other thing that was really funny to me
was uh during our break uh it reminds me
the way i bowl
i mean i bowl and uh i don't hit the
pins
i hit the gutter and what i mean to say
is in this particular variation it's a
kind of a funny example of this bowling
ball b pawn going all the way up the
palm
it gets the north it gets ignored it
just it's a gutter ball all the way up
to b3 and no trades
and yet i find the position attractive
for uh white
yeah even with the pawn on b3 this one
this one is very unclear but yeah i can
i can see why
i would maybe be quiet as well it's
a very very strange strange position to
to judge
and because shaq took so long in the
opening and hans was playing pretty much
his
what's the time uh did uh
did hans catch up with shaq or is he
hans is actually behind on the clock no
way as far as as far as i can uh
this let me let me check this because
this seems counterintuitive no it's
correct
okay so hang on a second uh so hans
played everything instantly up until
queen e3 after queen e3 had uh
do two minutes up from the starting
allotment okay he took uh 15-ish minutes
so he went probably 90-92 yeah and then
and then he spent like 14 minutes on on
the move bishop d3 and then he spent
uh
25 minutes on the move queen g3 and he
is already
15-ish minutes in the tank after rookie
8. so uh slowed down
in a way in a way you can argue that b7
b6 there was
like a qualified success there for
shakira it may not have been the best
move in the game i think we pretty
safely can maybe even dispense with the
qualifiers right it was not the best but
not the best was not the best move but
it provoked it made hans think okay it
it's it switched hands from i'm just
repeating my analysis ha ha you yeah to
what is going on here and he's providing
decent solutions but he's burning a lot
of time and you can imagine the most
logical move rook he1 does need to be
considered very carefully because
remember this bowling ball pin you were
mentioning yasser yeah try it again on
your board
right and in this case with the rook on
e1 oops oops excuse me uh the bishop
shockingly might be playable anyway a3
bishop one rookie one i don't
necessarily hate as much maybe as i'm
supposed to be hating this because my
king now is extremely safe on b2 with
this pawn on b3 in front of it and the
dark square bishop gone
and then maybe we can finally switch to
giving mate on the king side you know
chess is tough
alejandro i mean
wow you just gave up the exchange no i
assume i assume i'm incorrect but right
like in a blitz game
zero ah okay
and here i'm sitting there you know
besmirching uh this bishop on a5 saying
you're the worst piece in the world you
just took a whole ruck
uh with this bishop this offside bishop
but uh speaking of preparation uh
alejandro how are fabi
and linear dem and lanier doing because
it seemed to me like both players knew
what they were doing up to this point
yesterday when lanier gets surprised in
the opening you know exactly what
happens when you're down to 40 minutes
already on the clock 5 is still with an
hour and 22. the only move that we've
seen since they're reaching that
position bishop to 85 was bishop takes
c5 and bishop takes f5 and linear is
back in the tank according to the engine
there is absolutely no choice you have
to take this bishop on f5 if you don't
you're just giving up this bishop on e6
allowing this knight on e5 to live and
you don't have a useful move at the
moment because rook d8 is of course
impossible i just take on d8 and there's
no move here that improves your position
bishop to c6 is going to come against
everything pretty much you'd rather have
this bishop on the light squares alive
than this dark squared bishop so bishop
takes f5 is the only move here lanier
probably understands that and he has
played bishop to xf5 as i can see but it
takes him a while to be reassured of
what's happening in the position five
has no choice plays the move queen d5
immediately attacking this bishop over
under
over under on the thinking time here no
this one is gonna be a solid
10 or 15 minute thing right even though
he knows queen definitely even though
queen d5 is forced but the thing is he
has not now he has real options right we
were including bishop f2 f2 which i
don't imagine he'll ever play rook f8
which i can imagine somebody playing and
queen e6 which i can also imagine
somebody playing this this move queen e6
uh bishop f2 i don't think so
maybe he'll calculate it calculate it to
a draw perhaps he can be influenced a
little bit by their game in the american
cup which was very similar from the
psychological sense where favi comes up
with the preparation and then lanier has
a bunch of choices and they all kind of
look similar but one of them was a
fourth draw
and lanier was almost there in his
calculation like almost reached the end
of the variation of the force drop but
he didn't make it all the way and he
decided not to go for the line and ended
up playing something else
was tortured for forever and ended up
losing the game because he couldn't
defend on like the 60th or 70th move
so a little bit of shadows of that game
in which favi again out prepares his
opponent it doesn't necessarily mean
that he gets a better position it just
means that he's putting the pressure on
the board somehow right for me peter i
don't know about you but
i've got this light square bishop on f5
i want to use the light square so i of
the three choices queenie
bishop f2 i find myself drawn to rook f8
queen takes
c5 queen a4
rook d2 queen b3 the most obviously i
want to use
the light squares queen takes c4 yeah
yeah yeah i was going to trade and play
i think if we're playing the same game
anyway including rook g8 max makes also
uh perfect sense after rook d2 yeah
instead of queen b3 i think if we're
taking on c4 next move why we should be
bringing more pieces in right fair and
alejandro showed this line it is one of
the ways to equalize here i think of the
thing of the options black hat the three
yeah i think rook f8 is maybe the most
human if you spot the idea of just
allowing the same game trading the c4
pawn eventually for the h3 and no
senores bishop f2
on the board calculated by linear let's
take a look at how those lines are going
to go because this is going to be fun
bishop f2 forces the move queen takes f7
check there's no other option if you
want to get cute and try to uh
try to smother maybe i forgot it for a
second it's mother made with knight h6
queen g8 uh no it's not gonna happen
bishop e6 forks the queen and the knight
and that's the end of the game right he
can't take on f7 with the knight uh you
have to recover your material you don't
have time for rookie two because again
bishop e6 so queen takes f7 check only
move king eight shade is absolutely
forced that's the only move in the
position and now again i don't have time
to play something like cute like rookie
two attack both bishops because rook
fade attacks the queen defends his
bishop no time for that you have to play
after bishop f2 queen takes f7 checking
in chad you have to take on f5 now this
doesn't make any sense for black to give
up so much unless you take back some
material so bishop takes e1 is forced
another question is what do you have in
this position there's a couple of
threats there's a couple of ideas you
don't have to take on e1 immediately now
rook takes e1 or kda the engine is
saying is equal it's not necessarily a
draw it's just equal white retains
compensation by playing h4 h5 this
knight on e5 certainly provides
compensation for the exchange and the
fact that you're going to be playing
against the weak king might be something
that's attractive for favi now if you go
directly with a move like knight f7
check king g8 you could still make a
draw according to the engines with the
move rook d6
hits the queen hints at the fact that
knight h6 might be a threat still not so
clear what it's going you're going to do
after king h8 according to the engines
this absolutely forces the move queen a4
nothing else is good in that position at
least that one is pretty logical and i
guess for example a move like queen d5 i
don't know how deep linear saw in this
position but he has only one move not to
lose in this position it's to move rook
e7 just to prevent smother checkmate on
g8 did he see all of this we're gonna
have to ask him after the game perhaps
fabi will ask the question on the board
because linear must have calculated a
lot to be able to play the move bishop
f2 and queen f7 as you prescribed
alejandro on the board we're waiting for
queen takes f5 uh can we just see those
positions for a moment there peter
because
you
you you do start to think as is uh fabi
you know
uh
you kind of start to think
okay
i can even
no g6 is ridiculous right knight f7 chad
yeah we have to start with knight f7 i
think i'm pretty sure if we want to play
quote unquote
i was i was trying something i was
trying to combine something with rook t7
but sorry continue please yeah i i think
knight of seven check is
obliged yeah but it's interesting
like five is stopped here and i i wonder
if uh
fabi to be clear fabi stopped here yeah
here and he hasn't i mean kuna five is
absolutely the only move he'll play it
quickly
but
the question is like how deeply has he
analyzed this position and also
if his analyzer deeply enough i'm
expecting him to probably go rook take
c1 i think against against lanier who
has already played bishop too and
is showing a willingness to to calculate
not to have to defend some position with
uh you know
not entirely defined borders but to just
calculate his way out of trouble
uh if you play knight f7 check here
those variations that alejandro's showed
after rook d6 in particular yeah nov6 is
such a cute move because the point there
is if we let's put this uh put this on
the board first okay can we start with
rook t6
ah rook takes e5 exists which worries me
but then but then the bishop is hanging
yeah maybe maybe we can yeah maybe we
can uh it well the difference is also
rook fade
maybe
rook f8
a fate maybe okay if i if if i'm playing
with fire let me not play with fire but
the point is rookie six just forces the
queen away from e6 squares g6 squares
all of those right all those squares
queen a4 queen g5 and
yes those are strictly the only moves if
you play king of f8 here i don't know
exactly what you lose to but you just
lose to something maybe knight h6 yeah
because i've got a rook f6 and the queen
that looks
very very beautiful it looks a bit
rookie seven box but it's findable it's
findable because you know you know what
the threat is you know what the threat
is you realize that everything else i
think king of faith knight h6 is a
findable variation right uh so for five
the equation becomes i can take on f5
and then go knight f7 check and go into
this yeah uh again somebody who is not
on two minutes linear still has 40. if
lanier was on two minutes this may have
been an interesting an interesting
proposition right but linear is still on
40. you know we all know how strong of a
player he is
so by playing knight f7 check you're
saying i will show this extremely
beautiful variation the game is like
95 going to end in a draw because my
opponent is a very strong grandmaster he
will find
when when he only moves yeah when the
forest to either resign or find the
moves that make a draw he will make it
and by the way this position is
extremely beautiful because
if you go
uh knight h6 check first here
probably probably it's the same here 25
rookie 7 yeah there is a very very
beautiful perpetual here rookie 7 you
can play rook g8 check okay rook takes
d8 yeah and knight h6 here
we still cannot go to f8 because queen
g8 is made
nice so we go we go to h8 okay and we
just go knight f7 check
and we've given up everything apart from
this pair
and it still makes a draw against the
entire chess set
nice because otherwise you get mated on
the back rank exactly and that's the
special this professional is quite uh
quite beautiful yeah that's your back
rack mate everybody but yeah so
basically if you go for this with white
against linear dominguez in 40 minutes
you're saying this is a very beautiful
end of the game let's show this to the
viewers shake hands and make a draw
right or on move 20 uh
uh six
you can take only one
and play a chess game right where you
have an exchange down and upon exit but
a good night yeah but and
once again
assuming as we i think should by this
point that he's looked at this quite
seriously
he must know he's not better here if
black plays well right but he also
doesn't really look like he's running
too many risks because the king on h8 is
quite weak as alejandro said the plan of
h4h5h6
slow as it sounds it's not that easy to
parry exactly the knight on e5 is
extremely strong with the absence of the
c pawn does b5 b4 is not as scary not as
scary as it used to be right
and this provides you like it gives you
winning chances it also perhaps if you
misplay it somewhere along the line and
i don't know the queens get traded
somehow
you can lose this with white
but it's a game right so it's a very
interesting kind of a
little little crossroads for for fabiano
because
both are zero zero zero according to
what alejandro told us exactly but
they're very different zero zero zeros
one is an actual draw right and the
other one is
you know a chess game where black is
fine but there's still something i have
this image i'm on a motorcycle and i'm
coming to a fork in the road and one
sign says beautiful draw dead ahead the
other one says draw
but uh turbulent road
things can go wrong
it's it's pretty much exactly like this
now after you've been at 5 foot [ __ ] b1
and yeah we'll see shockingly he hasn't
taken another five even yet
what's he thinking about
indeed why is he possibly remembering
something right
he must have had this
in his notes if he's playing bishop take
c5 immediately
yeah
so once again queen takes f5 bishop
takes e1 and then i wanted to to pull
you both if you will
beautiful draw dead ahead
or
turbulent road likely draw are you
choosing rookie one you're choosing
knight f7 peter you first i think hugely
depends on how i feel on the day yeah i
think your mood is yeah your mood like
his by this point he's been you know
remembering some lines but also i'm
pretty sure calculating some other stuff
which is not mainline like i i feel in
particular with him now thinking after
queen of seven king h8
perhaps he hasn't repeated it
specifically today
he remembers some outlines and what you
do while in here is thinking
is
you are refreshing what you think is the
main line but you're also looking at all
kinds of sidelines
and that process of looking at sidelines
gives an experienced player a certain
feel
of just how well your brain is working
on the day right right right right if
you keep on like stumbling over you know
two move blunders in your mind
yeah which nobody will see because
that's that's happening entirely behind
the curtain you know exactly nobody sees
that but you you get the feel
of whether this is a good day for your
head or or not you know and if it is
let's just take the bishop and play and
if it isn't
maybe you know we've checked it's a very
interesting it's a very interesting
attempt linear did have to find some
non-obvious non-obvious things he chose
one of the better ones bishop f2 fair
play to him
move on and your take uh alejandro you
uh you call it the day or as you say as
peter says pardon me you you feel what
kind of mood you're in your your head's
working
and then you decide i think it's very
mood dependent but specifically for favi
he never runs away from a fight
and i feel that the fight here is to
take the bishop and not to go for the
forcing lines because as peter said you
can assume that a player of linear
strength and of his pedigree will find
the moves that he needs to find to
survive and he's probably already done
so because this position is so sharp and
so concrete linear must have already
seen a move like for example the rookie
7 resource coming up because it is a
line that even though it's tough to see
it's important and he is one of those
players that's very meticulous about
analyzing all of the variations that are
going to come forward in that position
so when he plays bishop f2 you can
guarantee that lanier didn't sit there
idly he actually sat there and
calculated all of this really
complicated things and you're thinking
well i'm not really going to trick him
there i might as well continue the fight
with rook takes c1 now if you were okay
with finishing the fight that's a
different thing but i don't think fabi
ever is he's the type of player that the
moment that he sees a fight he picks up
the gondola
uh good to know by the way uh game i
kind of uh slipped away from us a
difficult
challenge for wesley so when we left it
we thought
he's got to still work hard here
uh king f1 a5 and it kind of blew up
because wesley is here he's basically
trying to make some kind of a force draw
by generating immediate current to play
on the queen's side with this
b2 the interesting point is uh he didn't
go rook a7 he goes rogue b2 here uh rook
a7 does win the uh the pawn on a4 back
but then i guess we play bishop i'm not
sure which square
there's some we're choosing
okay
yeah yeah i'll just throw it out there
right he won and then we go uh rookie
six and at the end of the day we will
and it comes back to it so yeah we will
be able to let's say let's say rook c4
yep rook c4 rookie six checking f7
rookie two black goes let's say g5 g4
my feeling is
out of the 10 games between these two
players from here white wins maybe three
that sounds like a lot to me but yeah so
let's switch to the lavon game as we can
see the handshake i think oh we're gonna
see a handshake oh absolutely look at
that position yeah yeah
we're gonna see a handshake
this one is over yeah uh in fact have
they repeated yes they have they're just
checking
looking around for the arbiter you know
those looks yeah yeah yet
uh just want to validate the three-time
repetition
and arbiter says yeah
you guys did your job yep yeah
we kind of knew this was coming and uh
but we knew it from afar and we're still
mystified if uh if the bogo indian can
make such a comfy draw
boy we're going to why aren't we yeah
we're going to be seeing a lot of bogo
indians in our future guys possibly yeah
but yeah i don't know if it's you know
supposed to make such an easy draw every
single time if you're if your name isn't
magnus carlsen though that's a good
point yeah so
yeah it was a very i mean by the
standards of those two guys it was a
very very quiet game but
those do happen occasionally and we
we could see it from afar as you
mentioned yes exactly not a shocker for
us this is how this game concluded
uh the uh the burling on the other hand
is going to be still quite an exciting
end game i think western wesley so yeah
i think wesley probably saves it but
it's become it's become a bit touch and
go because we can still go rugby 67 here
by the way i want to give a tip
to the autograph hounds
if you just saw that
brief thing there lavonna roni if you
ask lavon aronian for his autograph he's
going to give you his initials like he's
just done it on a scoresheet so i said
to lavon i said lavon this is for
a friend could you give me your
autograph but could you do it in
armenian
and he did this incredibly beautiful
you know uh cyrillic type of signature
but it was it wasn't cyrillic it was the
armenian uh
alphabet it is it is
it was very very beautiful and i said
get rid of this
so just for you autograph hounds when
you go
on
say lavon could you do it is in our
medium anyway sorry uh to interrupt you
uh mvl
the difference between this position and
the one we were just discussing after
okay seven is if you have if we play
rook d7 sorry rook d6
here
uh yeah
yeah rook beat oh so rook a7 we were
saying you were saying three times you
might win i was saying ah that sounds
like a lot but rugby two yes sorry uh we
can still play rook d6 yes but then
after rook city two rookie seven
king f7 let's say rookie 4 c6 c5
black has legitimate count to play the
bishop probably lands on d4 becoming a
very very active piece and then we can
put the rook behind the a file with the
a pawn all of our pieces are active yeah
and it feels like this is probably uh a
better version a better version of the
same yeah and uh
interesting choice by wesley because uh
i think
there must have been at least some
temptation to defend passively but he
chose to to go for this one and a very
interesting move by mvl which i would
like to have explained to me c2c3
what's the reply to rook 87 let's have a
look-see
okay well at one point i'm going to land
here right sure so i guess he wants
rook d6 okay for bishop before in some
order right nothing else makes any sense
to me right so let's put that on the
board but okay
so which one first rook d6 let's go
let's go rookie six the point is here
after rook takes a4 we we're not in time
to take on e6 yet
because after king of seven our bishop
on a5 is in trouble sorry yeah exactly
back oh come on
go back
it'll listen
i don't know about you uh the problem is
is the immediate the desirable rook c6
and that fishbone a5 is uh i'm i'm
guessing we will have to interrupt this
really really riveting end game because
we have a we have a lecture in studio as
we get uh
magnusof
in a second yeah but we
okay i mean so how do we make a draw
here with black
i mean you you can you can immediately
get three against
two yeah
yeah i think we're okay here with black
bishop takes and just take on c3 and
play king of seven we shouldn't be
losing very many of these right
although page six is annoying
sorry don't drop over to you alejandro
as world champion magnus carlson in
studio world champion magnus carlson
curly one and a half out of two magnus i
have to ask you were mystified here why
doesn't everybody play the bogo indian
and make it look easy the way you did
obviously there are
uh there are many
many good openings for for for black um
i guess i i used to play this line
um
many years ago i played it against him
in the candidates and
and
in 2013 and then i just
i think i made some weird move like a6
or something instead of taking on c4
this is supposed to be fairly
harmless i feel like there was
sort of one interesting moment in in the
game
um where he um after queen a5 you could
have gone for e4
yes we were looking at that we were
actually also about queen c4 yeah so
exactly i mean i thought like
objectively the best was knight a4
[Music]
like at least there's bishop against
knight i mean i guess it's nothing but
uh
um
uh i mean
after uh but the critical line was e4 or
at least the most forcing line and yeah
here i thought
maybe knight g4 but exactly b6 was was
the key
yeah b6 was the key and then i thought
it was i was getting out so it was not
um and it didn't feel like i'd done
anything particularly wrong so it would
have felt pretty unfair if i was
if i was considerably worse there but it
i just thought for a bit just to realize
that b6 was
was um was kind of okay there um you
don't feel that levon is the one that
feels he didn't do anything wrong and
he's white didn't get absolutely
anything from the opponent no no but i
mean there are other ways to play for
instance you can block to check with the
knights
it's true
all the way back in before all right
but uh let me undertake that bishop too
inaccurately no no
i mean there are there are deviations of
course but i think he
um
he wasn't particularly aiming to
to play very aggressively against the
line that i played um i think he was
like
seeing if he could get one or two
opportunities and when he didn't he just
steered the game towards the drawn in
that sense queen c4 is a very good move
um since it kind of forces my hand
um yeah if i don't
if i play like bishop d7 then he has
knight e4 which is
um at least some sort of moral victory
for for him so i have to go 95 and then
yeah things are just getting chopped off
well we're going to ask you a question
since you finished so early how do you
evaluate this position in particular
we're thinking about this one between
fabiano carano and linear dominguez
seems like favi got his prep in but he
thought for a while before deciding
whether he wanted to take only one and
continue the game or play a move like
knight f7 and rook d6 how do you make
this kind of decisions over the board no
i think um he probably knows that both
lines are zeros and then he's
trying to recall if there are uh what
the critical moves are or and if there's
any
if there's any risk involved in playing
rookie one that's what i would guess but
my guess would be that he doesn't
remember
a lot from here just that it's supposed
to be
supposed to be zeros and that uh he's
not risking too much well thank you
magnus a job well done today with the
black pieces i don't like to think of it
that way
how do you like to think of it no it's
just um you know i think nobody really
loves these games but
at this level they happen of course of
course they do happen once in a while
well magnus good luck in the rest of
your games thank you
indeed uh magnus uh good luck for you
and again peter i think that magnus
really hit it right on the head this
move e3 e4 is the most challenging move
yeah that was that was good
yeah
b7 b6 this is a key move we missed it
completely yeah totally i was looking
mainly at knight g4 he mentioned 194.
but when you stop and think about it the
move b7 b6 is a rather hidden little
cutesy uh i mean you're you're uh
prepping this um tempo gainer bishop
a6 and uh well
for those of you who've got your
computer engines on
rev them up because this is this would
be a very interesting challenge and
maybe e3 e4 was a missed opportunity no
i think i think black is fine i think
both knight g4 and b6 should be okay and
honestly if you if you're feeling like
revving your computers up this is maybe
not the position to do it in because
there's
so many more exciting questions in
today's round that you can you can spend
your well let's ask lavonne what he
thinks what do you think about them
apples ah sure okay uh back over to you
alejandro here with lavon adonian lavon
it didn't seem like much happened today
but certainly you were trying where did
it go wrong you mean those blizzards and
thunders
did not impress you
yeah you know
i mean
in your opponent place you should before
check you should normally play knight
bd2 but since i didn't expect it i
thought well i gotta
just play solid you know uh
i think i had a difficult game yesterday
so i was trying to just you know not to
blunt her talk to us about yesterday it
seemed like you came under pressure in
one of your favorite lines what happened
there
i mixed up
fifth move which is
i mean
chess speaks for itself
you held that game you felt that you
were under a lot of pressure how did you
evaluate it in the middle of the game
yeah i thought uh it's a very difficult
position and
i was uh very angry at myself
but uh
yeah
somehow it's not a blitz i'm not
blunder pieces so
i just relaxed and
defended of course it's
not a great way to start
but held a draw there now draw against
magnus carlsen how are you taking this
tournament we know that you've been
playing back to back to back events in
india miami you're here now how do you
feel physically and what are your
perspectives towards the rest of this
thing field um
yeah i got sick in india and i'm still
kind of still recovering i really don't
feel uh
particularly well but
you know well i mean
i
always overcome and
i will do it this time as well i'm sure
so
it just takes time to to find the form
absolutely well a magician on and off
the board that 100 we'll let you rest up
for the remaining of the tournament
thank you for joining us thank you no we
won't no we won't
i was i was going to say we live on
we're going to go e3 e4 why didn't you
play e3 e4 come on
he he said that magnus said it was a
critical and he's gone and he's gone and
he's gone um
and honestly this position i'm less
interested in but i didn't okay i'm
slightly aggrieved that we didn't get
magnus's perspective on on the berlin
end game and now one has also gone from
our studio another person who knows a
thing or two about
uh berlin then games true true uh but uh
yeah all all of that experience just
disappeared yes just walked off as if it
was nothing decades decades of knowledge
yeah let's let's take a look at this
once again just yeah we're on the uh mvl
rookie two places wesley uh game and we
were
peter i think we were playing bishop
before
yeah and i think c5 is logical because
you don't really want to the one end
game i think i would like to avoid here
with black is
uh down upon with the extra pawn being
specifically on c3 yeah something like
this unless we have an immediate draw
with like check check and attacking they
have to pawn but i don't think it works
right
the king is reasonably safe on let's say
the e3 square okay
and yes there is some g5 g4 count to
play here even this might end up being
holdable but i would prefer to not play
this type of an endgame so let's go all
the way back and play c5 on i move on
move 31 right rook v6 here
sorry rook d6 here yes absolutely c5 uh
captures on the c file happen rook takes
e6 happens we play king f7 and i think
it's specifically the move rook h6 that
mvl is pinning his hopes on because it
looks like it might be provoking h5h4
and then
weirdly like if we if we play h4 here
okay uh alpha yeah let's say you've done
what yeah if you imagine even the rooks
coming off
and my king getting to g4
this might be just winning right because
i will play f4 i will break the chain
and then i will actually win the pawn on
h4
f2 so yeah
here it is three against two on one
flank which generally is quite quite
safe right but this specific structure
because of the bishops yeah this
specific structure worries me a little
bit as black i'm not entirely certain
that it's as
so as
a winning idea it would be to
put our king on f3 put a rook on e4 and
try to get the king over to g4 yeah and
to put the king on g4 that's
it's very long-winded black is of course
not obliged to comply with all of this
like black will have things to say about
this entire this entire sequence but
um i feel like this is what mvl is
planning for and i think we are very
likely to have this exact position on
the board pretty soon because rookies
already on the board yeah they're
heading in this direction
and
my knee-jerk
is that
that's a draw yeah but it's it's still
something that you can definitely
continue trying in because
uh
black steel
you can definitely see how this goes
wrong feel like exactly the contours of
putting your pawns on the dark squares
and bishops of the same color and things
of that nature how did uh
how did the
engine
start to evaluate this three versus two
again it's the presence of the bishops
alejandro that is giving white
um
that extra but
is it enough point zero one
not enough
i don't know
this entire line that you guys mentioned
here with rook takes a4 bishop b4 c5
takes
takes on c3 check here king f7 rook here
is as good as any other move the problem
is that according to the engines you
don't have to play the move h4 if you if
you play the move h4 then it's only
point four still very holdable but you
still get some ideas as you mentioned
the dark um dark squared pawns could
become a target with the bishop coming
to e3 right but according to the engine
it's easier to just first hit the bishop
force it off this diagonal somehow let's
just put it on e3 because why not and
then play the move g4
and now you put your pawns on light
squares instead of dark squares not so
easy to attack you can imagine that if
you could win this pawn immediately
then you're golden but unfortunately
after rook h4
you have this check and the point of
this check is that after king a2 rook a4
you don't have to move f3 and you're on
time to bring your king later to defend
this pawn on g4 so the engines just
think it's a draw all throughout typical
berlin maybe white has a little push but
it's never enough so let's focus on more
interesting things yes let's go to hans
niemann against shakhma medyarov because
we did see this bowling ball wrong roll
down the but not completely the gutters
did hit a pin b5 c5 b4 c4 b3 we had
mentioned this already and instead of a3
here hans took on b3 which is actually
in this particular position the engine's
choice
it does like the pawn on b3 in this
particular one of course bishop takes e1
was the choice it wasn't absolutely
forced bishop before also possible rook
takes e1 and the engines were pretty
adamant about breaking through the
center using the fact that this is a pin
to play either the move d5 or d6 in this
position just taking advantage of the
fact that e takes d6 is not possible
putting some pressure on this pawn and
somehow liberating this bishop
especially towards the king siding case
that i needed instead shock went in a
completely different direction played
the move a5 no surprise about what this
moves about wants to play a4 wants to
target this pawn on b3 but is it a good
move the computers absolutely hate it
they want this move queen h4
attacking the pawn on h7 you have to
defend it somehow and only when h6 is
played then retreat with the bishop to
d2 what is the point that now queen e4
will be coming in certain positions and
of course queen h7 difficult to meet
because the h6 pawn is currently hanging
instead bishop d2 was played immediately
and this is the current position on the
board the engines think that the best
move and by far by the way in this
position is to play the move queen e7
what's the point first of all you take
away h4 from the queen so you don't have
queen h4 e4 yes you can play queen h3
and attack the pawn but you don't have
queen d3 to follow up right bishop is
still stuck there so queen e7 also
attacks the pawn on c5 that's not so
difficult to explain and the only thing
don't do don't play a4 don't play a4 in
this position because this is the point
of retreating the bishop to d2 is that
now i can sidestep this pawn with the
pawn to b4 and of course this is gonna
create a beautiful umbrella for the king
to just land on a3 completely safe and
out of harm and then i can focus my
attack on the king side the agents think
that this position is slightly better
for white but i don't think anybody is
looking at it from that perspective but
more importantly in my opinion hans
demon move 21 20 minutes to go shakira
media of an hour and seven
so a big time difference there between
these two players wow thank you for that
alejandro and i just wanted to ask you
quickly i know we're preparing to go on
a break here but uh
i don't think i've seen that in my games
that five two ambassadors
yeah you picked up on that as well right
it's pretty cute i mean i have had
obviously uh many many times single
amphisons but i never had a double how
about you did you have a double not
really but uh there there's been a very
very important sort of breaking
development in the
karana dominguez game so let's go there
and just jump
give give the floor to alejandro
uh oh well
that was the movie you didn't like rook
f8 right rook fade was not a move i had
mentioned in this position after rook
takes he won the move rook a d-8 right
and the engines when i got here said
it's the only move
everything else loses whoa so rook 88
tactically the point is that if you play
knight f7 checking g8 you you could take
on d8 nothing's preventing you from
doing so but it doesn't win the game
because i can take your rook on e1 and
after king d2 rook e7 only move
is sufficient for a draw according to
this engine gotcha so that was forced
but rook f8 came on the board and fabi
hasn't played yet but the engines are
thinking queen d7 and why not
and it's plus six
what plus six end of the game let's go
to the next one the point seems to be
the knight f7 followed by rookie seven
can be very strong or you can play
knight f7 and again this ideas of knight
h6 can become an issue i'm a little
surprised that there's no defense here
but apparently this everything is just
too stuck there's no good way to bring
the queen to the center to fight for the
file and i think that's why the engine
wanted to play rook 88 particularly in
that position because now that the queen
reaches d7 and controls all the
important squares there's no way for
black to get his pieces into the game uh
sample variation rook takes f4 why not
just bring this rook to f8 next move
check now if you take on f7 and i take
on f7
unfortunately you start to see
the difference in power
between the pieces
open files rookie check is checkmate
queen takes c4 if the queen moves
somewhere dumbledore and if you play
queen g6
takes takes rookie 4 rookie 7 a4
whatever the same game is hopeless
yes it's that bad the king doesn't get
in the structure is not good for the
activity of the king because they can't
enter through the queen side and even a
move like a4 just to isolate the pawn on
c4 the engines are saying this is a
completely winning end game for fabiano
caruana which i'm sure he will
convert without any difficulties and if
you don't take on f4 where are the
useful moves here the most shocking
thing uh once again i'm sort of reading
your screen and
all you said you can sort of understand
but if we can bring it back to
alejandro's screen there for a second
queen d7 rook takes a four yeah right
if i if i understand correctly you can
play queen g2 here and white is still
better
what
that is what the engine says correct
yeah and i mean and this i specifically
wanted to show because this is one of
those which like you send screenshots of
this to your friends right
we're an exchange down the rook on the
four can be supported by rook af8 right
we have no threats we've just moved our
one act like nobody plays queen two it's
a horrible move knight of seven is
winning but i just wanted to show it to
our audience because it's one of those
things you occasionally see on your
computer screen and you just immediately
press like whatever you use for screen
grabs like
yeah yeah yeah
whatever yeah right and you send it to
like five people and say yes the second
move here and the evaluation
that's crazy why is this better for you
97 against most things they must change
like yeah even a move like
like yeah why is rooker 5 losing like i
have no idea rookie 5 loses to queen
december
okay fair enough but queen d5 also very
strong now again preparing knight f7
check and using the fact that it's a
background right you don't have time to
play rook f8 because you play check
anyway take and take
so you you you guys are into alien
worlds it's really really crazy we're
going to take a break absolutely we're
going to re recharge ourselves there
queen d2
get out get out of here we're going to
see you all on the other side of this
break stay tuned
[Music]
and here we are with robert thomas in
the sunflowers chess club uh during the
sinful cup at this moment happening in
the next building uh robert tell us your
impressions you just came out from there
so how does it feel to be there yeah i
mean it was pretty cool uh definitely
something that i haven't haven't seen
before i've always been a big fan of
chess so
i've been watching them online and on
the streams and stuff but just to be in
that room and kind of feel
feel the
you know all the powerful thinking and
all those plays is uh it's pretty cool
yeah and
my routine for this tournament actually
who is your favorite player
uh you know what i've probably followed
him the longest uh just because i know
his name is magnus carlson i think he's
uh
he's obviously the best in the world and
uh someone who i've followed since i was
you know a lot younger than i am now
yeah i mean and also i noticed that you
are checking the games carefully i also
know that you are really decent players
so how happened did you
you play chess
i probably play
uh you know i try and play once a week
for at least an hour i played it a lot a
lot more when i was younger but i you
know started to get back into it the
last couple years so i try and get at
least an hour and a week uh and just
kind of practice a little bit yeah
uh i'd say my friends uh me and my
friends used to play in the chess club
back in uh elementary school and i was
playing tournaments around our local
city so i i think it was just a fun way
to compete with friends and uh yeah
something that we always uh you know
have had a lot of fun doing yeah and you
are here in st blues for many years
already playing for saint louis blues uh
hockey team and how does it feel to be
finally in st louis chess club itself
yeah it's something that uh obviously co
would code happen so i couldn't come
here earlier but uh some place i'd
always wanted to come and couldn't be
better a better time to come than having
this tournament here so
uh yeah very excited and definitely a
place i'll have to check out a lot more
yeah i hope so and we're looking forward
to see you again at st louis chess club
as probably will have a chance to play
more games thank you so much for today's
yes
thank you
[Music]
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums art history science
even
magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
[Music]
kids it is
st lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back to round two of the singfield cup
with plenty of action still going on one
game ended in a draw and there was the
game between the two people in this
round who played against each other the
most and in general i think are very
close to
the top of the list of
all time i would suspect i would suspect
so too we're of course talking about
magnus versus levon and this round two
they were the first game finished uh
peter
yeah it did seem to be a bit of an
uneventful game and levon i think was
very honest in an interview he didn't
try to sugarcoat it he said i struggled
uh yesterday kind of tricked myself in
the opening yes he did and then had to
first of all get the you know self
cursing out of the way and and then you
know hunker down and defend a very very
annoying position for a very long time
which he managed which he did manage and
today when he got surprised in the
opening he felt that you know going for
the things which would have provided
that with us with a much uh sharper
fight but perhaps where what magnus
expected
did not seem appealing and in the gct uh
tour standings let's take a look at
where things are coming in to this
tournament and why things are so close
peter
as you can see on your screen here with
everybody having played uh three events
apart from richard rapport
mvl is currently in the lead there with
26 and a half for gct points and the
most money earned as well alireza's in
second after his very very
convincing victory in the just
very recently concluded uh wrapping up
leads in st louis
and levon and wesley are tied for third
on 22 and a half the hunt is very keen
between those top players isn't it and
this is how we see the graph i always i
always like those graphics i like
perugia hitting the trampoline take a
look at that from poland to
croatia but st louis really uh got him
nice on the graphic
all the way up there yeah and fabi is
somewhat somewhat behind but if he has a
good event here he uh he's definitely
still uh in with a shot for perhaps uh
third or maybe even second i hate to be
cruel to fabby he's been in a bit of a
slump i mean that
candidates wasn't great either there we
saw that just that kind of line where
yeah and uh
unfortunately yeah on topic on topic of
fabia we went on a break after uh
showing our viewers and uh if if you
were here uh you perhaps have caught us
uh explaining that queen 27 on move 27
was incredibly incredibly strong
and probably just tweeting but yeah
we're watching this game being trapped
uh yeah we do expect this game to finish
and by the way i mean i
kudos to wesley so uh
an ending that you mentioned yourself
that sergey movisian had lost it to
alexander but i think sergey sergey
tried to defend it passively and that
eventually led to his downfall whereas
wesley took some time straight out of
the opening there and ran for this
really really concrete plan of opening
up the queen side it did cost him a pawn
eventually but he managed to get the
entire queen side off the board and then
three against two on one flank
let me tell the audience what you're
talking about right here
uh way of playing it passively would be
for example to attack the bishop
what wesley did was immediately uh blow
up the queen side even as you said peter
at the cost of a pond got his pieces
active
uh ended up losing the pawn but then
securing the draw so two draws in at
this round two game but now to continue
your point
how could papi not play the move queen
d7 he's just not himself i think i think
fabi uh when he's in good form i think
he would have uh
it's i don't think we're slightly over
selling how obvious it is because i
think giving up the pawn on f4
and white is still better after queen e4
just not as much uh i think maybe this
is what let him down is that the
realization that there is a good move in
the position and why are we searching
for better
but 27 was significantly better 27 was
basically as we were as we were saying
basically winning whereas after queen e4
the game is still very very much in
progress well we have a couple of moves
since the move uh queen e4 right we'll
have this move rook d8 and the engine
absolutely hate this move as well so
they were adamant that after queen e4
you have to play the move queen e6 and
you can understand this move it takes
control over the f5 square and now there
are no more real jumps with the knight
g6 is not possible f7 is not possible
you can always take on c4 you can always
take on b7 but it's not material that
white is playing for you're playing for
the initiative in this in this scenario
and the problem is that after rook d8
both moves g6 immediately or f5
immediately don't allow this queen to
return over to the king's side you're
gonna be able to play g6 at some point
knight f7 will always be an idea even
the idea of f6 and just opening up the
king that way following it up with king
b1 and king a2 just hiding the king from
any potential counterplay will give
white according to the engines a very
very very strong advantage so
dominguez was given this chance to play
queen e6 it didn't quite equalize but it
came close to that and he didn't take it
right and i've
personally peter i don't know about you
but i find the move f5 really compelling
because i want to go g6 i want to go
knight f7
and you know just plain game essentially
yeah and also taking away the e6 square
from the black queen again just be a
very very important thing here because
it if it doesn't get there your your
progress on the king side is very very
difficult to stop it's also very much
like alejandro mentioning that it is
very much worth it here to invest to
tempe king b1 king a2 right because then
you can more or less completely forget
about any kind of counterplay against
your king the the only reason i would be
a little bit
remiss uh if i didn't mention that king
b1 just does yeah in some ways yeah if
kunai exists you know so i can make a
perpetual you know those old standby
whereas for me the move you know i'm
really really really attracted to g6 but
i i would much rather have my pawn on f5
so i'm going to play g6 just so that i
can sort of swing
swing happily along the h file this
looks really good for for fabby right
now ga turned out to be bad sorry yeah
and uh just a very very cute kind of a
transformation in the game between hans
niemann and and shakha mijarov because
we started off we you know we spoke
quite a lot about
how poor how poor the black people
now there's once again a bishop on a5
there just a little bit of a different
color yeah change colors out well
and it's also not great i suspect but
probably better than yeah and shark says
yeah it's clearly better than than mine
was because he just gave up a rook to
trade for it
and we're just uh catching up as we do
have a special guest in studio
i don't know i can't well
that bishop was good after all it was
defending a good bond but let's uh
interrupt ourselves and jump over to
alejandro
here with the defending winner of the
singfield cop 2021 maxine welcome to the
show tell us a little bit about your
preparation today of course you must
expect to berlin from wesley so what was
your choice
yeah i thought
you know this
was the most promising i could find
and
yeah i assume i'm slightly better but
i'm honestly a bit
annoyed as myself to say the least like
i think in some critical moment i didn't
think for long enough so um well let's
take a look at it first of all were you
familiar with this position that you
reached about this game christian
yeah yeah i was familiar
and tell us until more or less you did
not know what was going on
yeah so
a5 you played a4 yeah it's natural i was
not sure about if i thought maybe
rook c8 bishop a5 c5 was an idea and
instead of a4 in this position instead
of a5
instead of ah instead of a5 you've got
rook here right away yeah bishop a5 and
c5
because you want rook c6 i thought this
was maybe the roxy six holding on to the
sixth round like because often i want
bishop c3 so like after bishop f6 i
considered for a long time bishop a5
bishop a5 immediately yes but b6
bishop c3
take take
okay there's king e7
that i missed
was the idea for cafe
but
my point was after rook d8 i couldn't
find a win
right you probably have to go into the
pawn end game yeah and the opponent game
i thought could be promising but it's
not so right
it's a good thing
because i missed completely this idea of
kingston or cafe
um so anyway
yeah and after rook b2 yes this
particular position
and here yeah i don't know what happened
to me so i i didn't see kingitu
but anyway
like
which is serious option probably draw
but you know
much uh
much more of a choice than what i did
but even after rugby two i thought hook
d6 rook d6 in this position yeah i
thought for d6 was uh
you have to take yes hockey six rookie
six king f7 rookie four yes c5 bishop e1
okay two let's say yes catching the pawn
yes g4 g4 uh-huh cementing these ones
yeah take take bishop
d4a5 and well maybe it's actually
nothing because you're in time for
bishop of six bishop d8
but i saw very nice and you pick up the
pawn also
like no bishop d8 you have rock e5 so
yeah but king kg2 actually i i mean i
thought wesley was doing nothing in this
position so you know when i was thinking
after i played c3 because basically i
stopped
at c5 bishop he won
and assumed it was a draw but right
although yeah it does think the engine
does think it's a draw anyway yeah yeah
it is but um yeah i thought c3 made it a
lot easier but then yeah i should just
be annoyed that having missed kingito
which
which was a more serious try yeah
probably draw anyway but interrogator
and of course the pointless for the
audience is that after rook takes c2
rook d2 and k2 yeah and this enemy can
actually be very dangerous for the box
it's not you know in dangerous realm
anymore yeah
that's true but yeah that's some peter
mentioned rook a2 in this position yeah
network g6 it's completely different you
get the extra tempo basically yeah yes
all right
very good
well we're going to ask you a question
here from one of the other games turn
off the engine so you get any hints
this particular position that we had
what were your thoughts looking at it
from a spectator point of view i thought
it should be fine for linear but at the
same time i feel like
fabiano looked at this sorry
and
yeah must have a comfortable
way of playing on so i think
if linear plays the best move it should
still be within drawing margin but it's
quite unpleasant yeah he didn't find the
best move and after rook f8 uh the
entrance thought there was an immediate
win in this position okay
so yeah i thought hook effect was a move
so no rockefeller was definitely not the
move the engine's thinking instead rook
88 was the move only move to maintain
balance tough tough yeah tough but um so
rook f8 i mean i didn't see a win
yeah they are just thinking queen d7
logical or difficult to find
uh
i mean definitely within like fabby's
abilities
[Music]
and you
like if i go queen b6 you just won
knight f7 rook e7 yes
yeah and no perpetual yeah i mean
definitely i could expect phobia to find
this still the engines like his position
a lot after the move rook d8 and g6 or
f5
yeah so g6 here i thought queen f6 this
is great f6
and if one takes hook e8
yes
because of the knight g6 i'm in time for
coin g6 yeah let's show that on the
board
and this is unclear but i don't think
black's in any danger i mean white could
be indeed yeah right yeah
um
but instead i mean after all d8 maybe
you can take on c4 maybe you can do many
things maybe you can go king b1
it looks very dangerous
can be one anyway yeah
all right can you oh no okay
but no no no you cannot take on f4 let's
show that right no this this is what i
thought this maybe i can do but queen
is there yeah
up a couple of pieces here and there
maxine how do you rate the start of your
tournament
um
no
at a slow start let's say two draws
and today i'm definitely not satisfied
with you know alpha chance he missed
he's still alpha chance right so you
know in this sort of tournaments
whenever you get off a chance you you
want to take it yesterday i feel like i
played well
i took a lot of energy of course to
remember the details and uh well
actually to not remember some of the
details but uh
um then i feel like i played a pretty
good game
um
but yeah i definitely like
need to
to rest to recover some energy and
because for some reason i'm not sleeping
as much as i should here
and then uh then we'll see all right
well we'll let you get that rest on as
the commentators have any other
questions for you no you asked exactly
what i wanted to ask yeah i we wanted
the expert opinion on just how easy q7
is i don't think it's that
straightforward
but yes it should be findable i think i
think it's still surprised that five
didn't play it in particular since he
didn't blitz out queen e4 he definitely
considered his options there and if you
if you stop to consider
now also to me the question is like
how familiar fabi was this
uh
with the fact that rook f8 is not
a move
and therefore should be punished much
more harshly than with queen e4 well
we'll get to ask him after the game
certainly we'll let you get your rest as
it's a long tournament thank you for
joining us maxine thank you thank you
maxine indeed and uh i'm looking at this
position between shaq and
hans niemand and i was just about to say
that hans
was using a lot of time and he finally
made his move uh bishop d3 to e4 is king
makes perfect still
somewhat exposed yeah exactly very
centralized king there but bish before
makes a ton of sense because black
perhaps was you know self-threatening
queen queen a4 so taking away the c6
square there
makes a great deal of sense i was kind
of widely checking if black can play
bishop takes c4 here while we were
listening to maxim
explain what's going on with him but i
don't think it's perpetual i think we
just got king d2 here and the checks
right now generally do run out i don't
think it's playable for black um it's
still a bit tricky i can play maybe
queen of four check in this particular
position and continue being a nuisance
but
it's not really much more than being a
nuisance right uh yeah can you talk to
check is sort of the justification for
what i'm doing and suddenly black i
think is winning but
unnecessary you can make pretty much any
any item of king c2 seems it seems
decent queen f2 rookie 2 and we've
finally stabilized
uh and bishop take c4 is unplayable then
b4 is definitely a useful move kind of
asking shah do you want to play c7 c6 to
stop me from bishop d5 right which does
stop fight from from getting bishop d5
in but on every other count is an
unbelievably ugly movie exactly you
never ever want to make the the problem
with such a move with c7 c6 is this
bishop could actually just get shut out
for the rest of the rest of it i i was
more though
i was more on i liked your idea of queen
c6 to a4 trying to sneak in through the
back door so to speak but okay this is
very concrete because rugby one might be
winning right exactly that was my
question for you too beyond queen a6 and
then i try to take everything on like i
take maybe with the bishop first okay
uh and now i take with the rogue okay
now i take on d7 yeah and queen g2 queen
c7
and you very often just
very quickly lose these types of queen
endings if you don't have the immediate
perpetual and here i don't think you
have the king before is it this is just
one check
and then it hides on like b7 here i go
here you go i go 26 here to give myself
some more squares right and then you go
and then it's crossing up the board and
start pushing i think there's no race
yeah i think the seatbelt just wins here
often than not i won't argue that point
yeah so
it's not obvious how shock should react
before um challenges challenges galore
the game kind of slipped by us and it's
going uh quite quickly is the one
between nepo and ali raza when we left
it we were more or less around these
parts we were kind of thumping the table
a little bit for bishop e3 he didn't
play your move queen c4 i don't know he
played queen a5 which is also sensible
uh yeah i still like the c4 squad if we
can park it on c4 and it doesn't get too
much but maybe rook g1 d4 is what is
very annoying here
i i do remember that after f5 bishop g2
obviously i only saw it very briefly on
our screen but if we go back to that
move 14
f5 bishop gto yes
the engines were at least or so it
seemed to me the engines were connecting
the idea of playing a five with the idea
of following up with the immediate e5
right trying to block off our bishops
with e5 exactly
and once you don't do that perhaps you
do get hit by bhp 3 very quickly as it
happened in the game and you no longer
really have the options that maybe you
would have had here because here i think
i can play queen c4 and if you play rook
fg1 i am in time to actually block it
off with the 5v4 and then castle next
move right and this seems to be
reasonably comfortable at least to my
eyes it seems to be kind of okay for
black but the way he did it he castled
and then after hp3
uh if you do it the same way
uh like like happened like it happened
in the game castle bishop b3 you put the
queen on c4 here i will play rook
foreign and you're not in time to play
65 anymore because bishop d5 check
happens
just in time for white oops and that
means that the queen on c4 is very
vulnerable to rook d4 ideas absolutely
so yeah understandable understandable
that he chose a5
uh uh
jan played c4 understandable that he
played f4 because c5 the white setup
might end up the wide setup needs to be
challenged right you might you might
find your queen offsides after a bishop
d2 somewhere somehow and uh before
somewhere here i think in particular of
the bishop before hp5 jan had a bunch of
options he could choose from but he
chose uh kind of a dry one
he's still going to be pressing but it's
still
not the most it's a very very technical
but did you think was rook fd1 is
interesting uh there's there's a few
things here i don't know it's you have
to analyze but for me uh i sort of never
trust my technique
uh so i would be strong with your
technique it's just not good nothing
nothing wrong with it it's just not
great okay so for me the end game he
went for i would be very reluctant to go
for it because i would think even if
it's better for white and i suspect that
it is
uh i'm just not winning yeah i'm
unlikely to play it perfectly
but yeah he's gone for this very very
technical position where
obviously if we if we stop at rook fd1
which i think we get by force right we
get here if if we play queen b2 on move
whatever it is 17 18. you just have that
image of the four rook uh you pretty
much get this position by force because
you you played bhp5 so you're definitely
taking on e4 here after queen bitsu
there is no choice after green takes d4
e65 is far and away the most obvious
move in the position you want to develop
some pieces you want to protect the pawn
and f4 and then we get there yeah we
give this check and pretty much every
single
move in the sequences forced
i want to talk about this for a second
let me just interrupt you and say
i get here move by move very
consequently
and i see this position in my my head
very clearly but i i do it by a move by
move michael tall gets to this position
by chunking are you familiar with that
concept if he just sees
all of these moves together like as a
package
and he says oh that's one
challenge or i don't play queen b2 which
is i think what you were alluding to
that uh nepo sees something else beside
queen b2 yeah i mean he definitely he i
think he spent some time on queen beetle
he definitely considered all the other
options as well do you chunk or do you
see it move by move you're giving me an
opportunity to tell one of my dad's
favorite jokes again which i you know i
will never pass up but uh do it do it do
it
it's a reasonably famous you know homily
about somebody asking asking a
caterpillar which move which leg she
moves after the 27th on the left
and it just stops and never moves again
because like once you involve
the higher the higher processes in this
in this like you can't do it anymore i
don't know you're asking me a question
which is a very legitimate question i
don't have an answer for you i have no
idea and the caterpillar doesn't know
why it means this 28th leg uh in the
sequence it does i have no i honestly
have no idea but i i that that concept
does sound like something that probably
is happening at least occasionally in my
in my head of just kind of
teleporting from point a to point b
uh with not very much going on in
between like you you start looking at
queen b2 and then there is pretty much a
seamless immediate transition to that
rook ending after exactly
but yeah i i wouldn't be able to say
that for sure
furthermore from that transition to the
four rook ending to this transition the
single rook ending with the pawn
structure favorable for white
uh is also an easy one uh to bring
forward now again i for for me i look at
this position and i say well this is
lost
that's the point i like to play it
though i like to play for white people
thank you very much
i mean you're very happy about this
challenge is really on the other my
opponent
and i don't know uh pick up on this uh
alejandro first of all are you a are you
move by move are you a chunker
[Laughter]
and secondly how do you like these
apples i i think uh nepo's in the
driver's seat on this one i never
thought about chest in that way i just
play chess
but in this move i move i guess it's
moved by movement that's what you call
it right yes but in this one i have to
agree with you completely yasser and the
computer agrees wholeheartedly it's
giving a very strong advantage to why
the full plus 1.2 and it's just the
easiness of making moves i'm going to
put my king on f3 i'm going to play g4
i'll probably play g5 if you let me
because if you play the move h6 at that
point if i capture i get two connected
past pawns and if you capture me after
rook takes i can start attacking your
pawn on g7 so king f3 g4 e3 e4 all of
these are possibilities for nepo they
play themselves out and i don't see
black's plan if this rook moves from the
c file if you don't start doing nothing
at some point you're gonna play rook c5
and you're gonna have to play c6 that's
a very awkward move to play i could
always go back and re-attack your pawn
on a6 so you're kind of stuck on the c
file which means you have to play other
moves something with the king but
where's the king going you can put it on
f6 i'll put mine on f3 i could start
with the move e3 it's what the engines
want so that king of three is not met
with the check uh apparently the rook on
c2 is slightly worse it looks extremely
unpleasant for the black side i don't
know if it's lost
but it looks really bad for lareza yeah
it's
the conversation here is i think by this
point specifically are we already lost
yeah have we already lost or is there
still a way to defend either actively or
passively i don't know i saw briefly
there on the screen that the engine was
in the current position of the king of
seven f4 it disappeared later but it was
i think a striking indication of where
we are in the game yeah the engine was
suggesting rook c1 here
roxy one and just abandon abandon ship
abandon ship and start pushing it
actually did not like rook c6 if you go
back a couple of moves even though rook
c6 was the only way to defend that pawn
yeah it just said
do it
let's go yeah abandon let's go uh pull
c4 c5 c4 but the issue is
normally three against two on one side
is very easily drawn but this is
this is three in the center against two
on the side that's right this is far
from easy and that past e2 pawn it's not
going to be a three versus two easy draw
liquidating into this requires either
you know hardcore knowledge
or you know a great amount of steel
exactly exactly real understanding well
keep an eye on that one again uh
hans by the way did establish five units
bishop on d5 though that's what i wanted
to say that uh
uh
well i mean he's gonna be more than
satisfied with
his play in these first two rounds is he
really did put some very annoying
pressure
on
in round one and then finally let's go
back
and a f4 f5 played by fabi
and
oh boy for lanier i think he's coming to
grips with the fact that he's got no
play and he's facing some very
very dangerous
attacking ideas g6
yeah just inside of seven is one i keep
on i keep on trying to figure out if
there are some situations in which i can
play f6 and then do something for fall
like f6 gf and then something i think
with the queen on a6 b5 no i think f6
with the clear 96 i don't think it works
but let's say if you play queen a4 which
is a really ridiculous move which
probably loses to a
lot
a lot of random random stuff okay okay
but with the queen with the queen away
from the sixth yeah here maybe we can
find some kind of a justification for it
but even even in this position honestly
i'm not sure why i'm doing this like gta
except for takes f6 knight g4 that's why
you're doing this because you're
thinking that you get on this diagonal
maybe we
are uh
is it that easy it's possible that we
are yeah queen queen e5 knight of six
i'm i'm
outrageous seven exists
but then
knight of six
is not a threat though yeah we
we randomly put our queen on a4 and
stopped our combination
he's a threat though but obviously g56
is just simple i don't know why i'm so
drawn to the idea of playing f6 instead
and he's playing the move b5 defending
that pawn on c4 i know i don't know if
there's a secondary idea to this because
i don't think which is actually kind of
funny because i was looking for a random
room movement i wanted to suggest b5s
but i wanted peter to show why he wanted
f6 no i think b5 yes dependency 4 is not
protected but mainly
it's that
black is like you would like to play
rookie 8 but you can't play
any rook to e8 because i think it loses
by force right and the queen has no good
squares
so let's just make a random semi-useful
move exactly
and just past the okay and let's take a
look at the most obvious and most
forcing we had some positions like this
i think right we always play queen of
six here right okay so
obviously we can win our back our
exchange but i think we were
somehow we were going down a pathway
that looked like this right this doesn't
look as horrible as it used to be
because if you remember queen takes yeah
check was a previous line
king takes h7 now exists for instance
this actually looks playable for black
because we're not really giving mate yet
gh doesn't look right so i mean what was
i going to have f5 right or that yeah
but i wanted to go for more like 5 i'm
returning the exchange i think i'm fine
but i'm returning the exchange king h7
is an attempt to perhaps even introduce
some winning chances into the position
okay so can i be uh
cruelly suggestive that i'm i'm playing
at this b5 before an idea
b
phi b4 probably not but i just want to
float this and uh
and see how how we think about this
b5 i think my my biggest issue is that
8x b4 and queen b1 exists
and i might not like that
but otherwise maybe it's something you
could attempt
uh i'm a little bit worried that g6 and
knight f7 might
rock your world here uh so long as i'm
not yeah ba a b or b a and a 2 even in
some positions right right if i'm not
getting mauled uh
maybe getting mauled though that's the
problem so so maybe they're sorry maybe
there's actually a point to to be b7b5
apart from just being a passing move so
you've got it so you say three yeah
now is there uh
now can i do i have time to get away
with uh
something as
menacing as this
well i can take on b2 you have to take i
think and now we can either give a check
on d2 and then find look for something
forcing or i can play queen of six and
say to you your knight is now pinned
which gives me kind of an important
tempo right yeah that's something next
move i don't know what that something is
but to do something next month that that
that is a g
annoying kind of a i'm not doing this
right uh help me out here alejandro jump
to my rescue
uh b5 it feels like there should be
something more forcing than what i'm i'm
i'm playing with uh for the moment help
me
i mean there's an engine line but you're
not gonna like it
okay it starts with knight c6
que pasa yes i understand you're putting
the knight on the wrong side of the
board but the point is that this rook in
particular doesn't have a lot of squares
you need to stay on the eighth rank that
i think is so is clear because otherwise
queen eight is gonna kill you okay so if
you play it to c8 97 the engines are
saying this is an improvement the knight
is on e7 which means that uh i still
have this knight g6 tricks
but i am preventing you from getting to
a lot of squares and now the move queen
h4 is also available
right here well rookie i think i can
play oh yeah and then i hear f6 and the
ideas if you take i have g6 all computer
all computer lines but it's the same
point as if i played knight c6 rook a8
so that i don't give this tempo right
right the same thing f6 pawn takes and
now here you don't go g6 you take on f6
you play rook takes
a come on
thank you rook takes f6 and here the
point is knight b4 with the idea of
queen d4 knight d5 so nobody's gonna
play this
nobody is ever playing that especially
somebody that doesn't play queen d7 is
definitely not playing knight c6 f6
takes takes knight before but
after b5 uh there are other ways of
playing you could play it quietly with
something like king b1
it takes the edge off b4 which for
example after h4 b4 is fully playable
this isn't a bad end game actually
because queen b1 takes takes remember
that f5 is hanging at the end
so so it's playable completely for black
again just giving zero zero uh so king
b1 just to avoid the move b4 is a
possibility you could start with g6 the
engines are not thrilled because okay
queen f6 is absolutely forced i think
that much is clear and you could get
your exchange back you would think
you're cashing in your chips a little
bit early but after the move queen c6
you still have a lot of threats queen
takes the 5 is impossible because of
rookie 8 as usual queen takes b5 is now
on tap so you have to give yourself some
kind of loft and give up the opponent on
b5 it's still a long defense for black
and the engines still think that white
is a lot better but the winning move
it's knight c6 guys
wow yeah this is not easy but i think
it's
once again first of all thank you for
that alejandro really at that knight c6
followed by 97 i wouldn't have guessed
it intuitively that the knight is
actually better placed on e7 but uh you
know
i was very gratified to see my my idea
yeah because with light on e5 it never
works because you play g6 you for a
second there you create no threats and
black is just in time to just pick pick
my knight up on e5 when it's 77 it's
much safer
once again it's findable and
if i being in good shape i would
actually take to play knight c6 if
you're here we don't play g6 for some
reason right but it was funny with the
knight on e7 uh like right here sorry
excuse me i wanted i i did it in the
wrong move order i apologize
rooks now we go 97
and now we can play now we can play f6
gfg6 and we are getting finally breaking
uh breaking uh to the king and yes uh
giving mate uh
i think it's possible to realize that uh
you know generally you don't want to
move the knight away from e5 because
you're like if the rook can come to ea
that's a problem but because we are so
much in control over the e-file i think
it's possible to realize night knight
ac6 is a strong move but it's not that
easy but but hold on there was a line
there where there was a queen
okay hold on rook g7 i'm wondering about
rookie seven queen eight queen c8
originally i didn't sequence eight
existed so i thought it was just a
blunder but we see it does exist in this
position
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
if i see this i stop with my knight c6 i
just kind of shut down knight so let's
try to figure out wait uh oh
uh oh rob d7 yes you'll move
rook d7
not f6 not g6 not
queenie
okay this is my big
oh
it is good isn't it oh
that's where i miss it on a puzzle rush
you know of course i see that it is
didn't wasn't looking in that direction
at all knight b8
dang yeah
so
once you piece some some parts of this
together right i think it's very
possible to realize just how strong the
idea is but you know it's not it's not
the most natural thing in the world
especially considering that you have
strong moves to
to fall back on like g6 is always
available
wow uh knight b8 okay that's a that's a
visual
alejandra what do you have for us hans
neiman's game good news and bad news for
fans of hansny with the good news his
position according to the engine is
winning let's see how he got there after
the moves queen e8 retreating the queen
so that on bishop d5 you can go bishop
b7 the engines were pretty adamant that
about after rook b1 you have to take on
d5 now it's ugly because you take on b8
take on b and you're even allowing me to
take with the c pawn white has an extra
pawn in this queen engine but the king
is still a little bit vulnerable then
you're saying that after queen b5 far
from easy the task is here for white
instead he played bishop a8 keeping
these pawns double but actually the
double pawns as we'll see later is use
are useful to keep the king safe after
takes takes takes takes queen takes d7
queen a1 check this is the current
position on the board the engines are
saying plus seven for hans team i'm
loving this queen and game for him the
only issue 40 seconds left for me let's
watch this wow
as we should
king be and uh 30 before correct four
seconds and king to b4 the correct move
yes queen takes
chuck realizes there is no perpetual so
he goes queen takes e5 straight away and
now yeah we just cooking the five kings
you just go king b56 collect that pawn i
don't think it takes a lot of
calculation to figure this out for hans
so i expect him to win this game whoa
whoa wait wait i mean now i see a race
before i didn't see a race queen takes
h2
king should i throw in h5 i i think
you're not going to give me your
your g pawn uh
but here isn't there at least something
to talk about or is it nothing to talk
about we're down a lot of tempe yeah i
think i think we're way too i mean yes
there is because all of these end games
they they're always slightly trickier
than you would expect but you're not
even threatening h4 yeah but why not
pick it up for yeah
what quintet queen is four queen d a
queen h4 are you right oops
no hansa i mean you kind of know hans is
winning but you also know that in
particular like but this is move 35 so
he is uh he's playing an increment
already but he is i think should be
reasonably well accustomed to uh to
playing on increment and his moves are
all going to be playing themselves right
kings is going to be quite
straightforward yeah c5 c6 i get it i
get it um still uh one one more look
queen takes h2 king c6 now i took i
think we should take one of two off the
queen off the king's seven i don't think
just just
rip all the pawns not just because we
won the pawn because i want i want to
have a check from aea7 i think it's very
important for for me to to be able to
get you a check from a7
queen a7 here but i get the feeling it's
just not going to be enough like king g8
i guess
queen b8
is it though maybe this is just a draw
now now i mean i obviously misplayed it
with white but maybe this is now very
close to a draw
queen c8 queen d6 right king e8
and now we start and now we start
pushing yeah h5 and we start pushing
pause and the king and the king only on
e8 is a kind of a really funny looking
piece where right the worst square maybe
b7 might still be might still be winning
for white though like queen d
c7 first maybe and then queen g7 and
then we surround years not queen d7 i
hope
i okay 27 queen of faith mate will be
okay so ben larson did that one he was
completely winning in a queen ending and
he got some position like this and he
did make the fatal uh
land mine square if you will
um
okay maybe there's still some tricks but
yeah but shaq absolutely needs to take
on h2 and he needs to take one to now i
think giving giving hans which raises
the question i mean since you can always
play king b5 and you want to do three
ride or h3 or make it a little bit
you know
make white work if you will to make
black work i don't i don't disagree but
kansai is playing in 30 seconds
there was no g3
there was no g3 we go back a couple
moves well there's a queen on e5 this is
where we start yeah but if you play g3
queen b2 king a5 can killing b7
and i don't collect the c7 pawn
i don't see how you do it
h3 or g3 we're not sure
and alejandra i'm just kidding
i missed seven that it's not that i
assume why this is still better but yeah
it gets tricky like i play queen d5 here
like my assumption would be i will still
win eventually but maybe not i i
i'm with you on that one peter i kind of
thought the same thing i didn't
didn't
it's the right thing to do you don't
really need to you don't really need to
worry about those races you you assume
you win this but
it's tricky as i mentioned it's always
slightly trickier than you would assume
all of these
green endings
once again uh one minute for hans uh how
many moves peter let's move 35 currently
so he has five to make but uh shaq has
all the time in the world
i i just like from a purely practical
viewpoint i just don't understand why
that pawn on h2 is still on the board
you're you're giving you're giving your
opponent time to think right and
if you don't take it like you will
you know the c7 pawn is gone right
there's no way there's no way to stop
that so there's no stopping yeah so you
need to generate some
some sort of
counter ghost of a counter play
somewhere so yeah
maybe he thinks quimby to check followed
by quintix f2 is somehow faster in terms
of generating passers but i don't think
it is i think it's quite clearly
optically
not the fastest way to generate
counterplay
meaning this is conceivably what avenue
yeah i'm trying to figure out what he's
thinking about uh he could be thinking
about right
but also i i think i look within the 8
25 check actually i think i go if you
play quina queen takes f2 here
i go queen eight king g7 queen e5 i love
that much much much and then i take on
seven with the king oh yeah
yeah
no more this looks done frankly truly
speaking of looking done yes i think
alereza looks done
what's gonna happen in
he's arguing that this holds but i guess
the threat is e5 king [ __ ] g5 right
this is maybe because if i still doesn't
generate an immediate threat so i guess
that was kind of banking on this
position holding on itself on its own
well not even close right i mean
i mean it just looks like a dream
position probably
i'm sure there's more than one way to
break this
passive defense if you just stay even a
move like g5 at some point will be very
dangerous
well dangerous yes but let's say
just for like as a as a thought
experiment king f7 g5 hg king g5 okay
king e7 just give you like give you two
tempe here and go back to e7 you play e5
i go back to f7
how winning is this terribly yes just
completely
just completely
the rook will one day make a grand
grand entrance as will the king
and uh that's all she wrote i'm afraid
yeah that's uh i mean if this is how it
sort of ends it's a very very nice
comeback game for or for yan who
suffered greatly yesterday just did not
get the position he liked right and also
like he will be the first one to say
that he didn't play it particularly well
like
right
but i know him well enough to know that
he will be his harshest critics and more
news
he might not have found queen d7
but fabiano found knight c6 guys wow
that looks like a much harder move to
find right nicely
on the board currently on linear down to
eight minutes still 11 moves for him to
make wow it might be that we have a
bunch of decisive games one after
another after the two drastic start of
the round
wow um
first of all thank you for that uh
breaking news i'm a little bit stunned
that ali reza would play this passively
thinking that allowing white to push his
pawns to e5 and f5 would somehow
still keep the game in a draw
that is a shock for me this is
a dream come true
uh for a nepo
and finally
wait a minute
no that it those are our three games
and currently our thinking is white
might be winning all three right yes um
white maybe even should be winning all
three is how we should be pushing it by
the way i find the move knight c6 to be
a lot trickier than queen d7 i mean i
would i would assume so as well knight
c6 in the game of fobby i mean i i'm
referring to that movement in particular
and there was a
now i can't
first of all
it's so easy to miss
this one i think that's a a real
visually beautiful move
rook d6 is it also queen eight by the
way we need seven here
here you don't have to find any
brilliances you just win immediately
that's right
and uh
well there was a
line
what was the line uh rook c8 97 right
um
and rook anywhere we go f6 g6 yeah this
is this this is what we're discussing
even rook c8 here still loses to f6 g6
f6 jfg6 yes queen h4 is a threat and you
cannot you can never play queen d6
because g7 knight f5 among other things
but among
i assume amongst other things but yeah
she was just crushing
um wow
uh sorry uh i'm i'm looking at rook g8
yeah
i guess gh is one way g8 yeah because i
i do get to play knight six check next
move
like it's it's such an ugly thing to do
but it kind of
makes me play knight g6 next which i
like
which i like
i don't like it
which i will enjoy i don't want it
um
boy uh knight c6 is really putting the
pressure in
and we ruxiate played bilinear he's left
himself i think how much time five
minutes for how many six minutes yeah he
gave he got a
30-second increment there 11 minutes ago
11 moves to go 11 moves well that's a
real challenge because 97 just plays
itself once you've played knight's e6
97 is an easy one i mean he clearly
played it to play ah
isn't this the one
rook d8
with the idea queen d6
but it's just i don't think it's fast
enough i think we already do f6 again i
can i think i can do it anyway yeah oh
man
g6 yeah
and i wanted to go queen g7 as we've
discussed right i always have g7 like
the queen can never go to g6 once again
that is that is definitely a landmine
square isn't it
that's the that's the royal fork
wow
um
which begs a question after this move 97
which is on the board by the way
how should
lanier put up best resistance uh
alejandro
uh it does seem to be
that move you were mentioning guys rook
cd8 but it's pretty lost i mean the
engines the more they think the more
lost they think that linear is now f6 is
apparently strong in this position uh
queen d6 immediately
is possible you cannot take on f6
because as you mentioned g6 and at this
point at least you force white to find
the move queen h4 which the engines do
say is winning you could start with them
with queen h4 maybe it's a little bit
easier to calculate uh the idea well
knight g6 knight takes fa just picks up
on exchange and keeps the winning
position
and it's very difficult to avoid so
there the engines aren't suggesting
anything fun or creative for dominguez
they just think this position is busted
sometimes chess is a simple game
and uh let's just uh check and it took
him a while
he actually did he actually played the
h5 and hans didn't play h3 or g3 or any
of that stuff which is ah a bit
surprising i would have just played g3
here
too i really i would have because kate
nobody's stopping king c6 i mean that is
not about but queen takes it very much
like quinte check here i think windy a
check here is a very cute idea the point
being i think is that if if you play
king g7 which looks very logical yes i
think the point is queen before check
and then g3
queen g4 check 24 check and then
whatever you do i will play g2 g3 and uh
i have suddenly like there's no more
counter play left i'm just taking on c7
next move and
that's a
powerful queen you don't have g5 h4
counter play but it's never going to be
fast enough i don't think
uh and if king h7 i think h7 maybe is a
slightly better choice practically
instead of king g7 but it's okay no a
previous one oh sorry
yeah here do do not allow queen d4 with
a check but the difference here though
g2 is a check right so oh excuse me
thank you so much i was like oh and then
i take one f2 next move and maybe we
still lose but it becomes a bit weird
right because we've probably had f7
the c5 pawn and no i don't want to walk
into the planet this is this is not how
i want this actually c6h4
yeah yeah yeah this one i can imagine
wait a minute hold on hold on you you
were sitting there louding the move
queen d a check and then you refuted it
no i didn't because i i think queen
takes a seven is a mistake i think the
idea here after king h7 is to play
maybe queen
f6 i wonder if that's what you mean
that's the gingerbreaking c7
queen
fs6 yeah quincy took c7 and the useful
checks have run out i mean you can check
from h2 but it's not very good i'm
threatening f7 and i'm still controlling
the h4 square very very importantly
meaning that yeah for black to start
running you will need to at least spend
a tempo on something like queen e4 here
or something right
but
uh hmm okay just a second yeah four
maybe even i don't know i don't know if
i want to allow queen h so
aha
queen
i mean it exists as
i i was just trying okay sure let's
let's see how this works c6h3
that's fast it's already it's pretty
fast yeah it's pretty fast you put your
king on the d file i've got you yes yes
all of this is all of this is not that
clear which is which is why we would
have played g3 or ah4 or h3 or something
uh quite a while ago and again i i'm
assuming the time is similar as before
30 minutes or more for shaq yeah has a
one minute
of times a little of time
about a minute from what i can see on
that screen yeah it's a bit too small
for me too i'm better than six yeah a
minute and six yeah
queen d a czech thought is it a major
difference uh alejandro between king g7
and king h7 i mean it's tough to ask
these questions to engines because the
engines just think that either way
white's going to promote a pawn so they
don't see the practical aspects of the
moves right there's a difference when it
comes to practicality
the engine thinks that king h7 is
slightly preferable
and that against king h7 uh the best
moves are either queen g5 holding on to
the pawn preparing g3 or preparing f4 a
little bit slow or queen f6 hitting the
pawn on f on f7 and again with the idea
of f4 now this is our engine moves
because they don't care how fast your
pawn is as long as my pawn is one tempo
faster right for them it's just a win
right but it's difficult to calculate
when you don't have that much time now
hans only has a few more moves to make
till move 40. so that's going to be a
key difference which one is a shot going
to choose in this particular position i
think
maybe you play
king h7 anyway just so that they don't
play queen d4 and repeat a set of moves
exactly
and i see in your background that it's
like a plus five plus six plus seven but
in the meantime
fabi doesn't play f6 and what much of
the advantage i mean he's still better
but much of the advantage is now gone
he's gone queen h4 the only way not to
lose on the spot here for black is to
play queen d6 but i think lanier will
probably recognize how bad his position
is and i think he is likely to actually
go for that
if queensland is here yeah can you see
another very uh long line we we kind of
have to go in with 96 check now okay a
king of fade okay we take on a f8
that's our experience
we've got our opponent
yeah queen e1 and queen of four check
very very importantly we have queen of
four check here okay and it gets awkward
because you can't like you can't play
king c talking b1 but then i will take
on a five for the check
very happily if you play queen g2 here i
have queen f1 check
queen g1 queen of four check back and
once again we're losing the f5 pawn with
check or we're accepting this perpetual
and if you play something like king d1
after queen f4 check yeah i will take on
fade f5 is hanging g5 is hanging the
king is in the center
uh the white queen does not have
particularly great squares you can
definitely imagine this not being
winning for once this is not the queen
ending we're seeing oh no the engines
are saying that if you want to keep an
advantage go through the entire line but
hide the king on a2 yeah so you actually
give up on a five-less check yeah you're
breaking b1 here no it's important to
play queen d2 according to the engine
although don't ask me why but the queen
only one is badly played so check check
and then we go king b5 king b1 queen
takes f5 yeah king a2 king takes a fade
and then at the end you go h4 and the
engine say plus one
yeah but uh but what is this comparison
obviously obviously you you don't like
you you can very very easily not win
this with very easily very very i mean
if you gave me that on a position over
the board i'd say i'm fine as black
right right like okay i'm a little bit
worse but i'm not even down a pawn now
why why is it that i ha absolutely have
to play knight g6 i i was reaching for
my rook
a moment ago rookie six
because i was thinking that i
at first i i hadn't fully realized that
my life was protected no queen queen
yeah queen takes a six maybe knight six
king g8 no queen takes e6 i wanted
just wins on the spot sorry yeah i'm
being dumb yeah okay
i got uh yeah i got that h7 so i was
reaching for my room so i'm not
realizing that my rook was defended
already on e1 so i guess we go queen g3
queen d3 knight five check night yeah
walking g8 knight of eight and maybe
even simply just rook or rook d like
some of queen of fun check maybe queen
of fancy is just an immediate draw here
because you can't really play anything
to one right
then i'm back to my f6 kind of tricks um
a mistake a a massive mistake i mean he
finds these beautiful moves and then he
mixes them up fabi's playing a kind of a
really accurate sag of a game here right
like he finds some really brilliant
things and then
he follows it up by missing by missing
very straightforward stuff in the
meantime i think jan is just completely
winning now as far as i can tell oh yeah
because you can go just to briefly like
rookie 6g no yeah i think it is right
just 66 g6 is completely winning though
rugby one we go rook c6
yep if that rook lands on g6 the game
just kind of ends and if you give checks
from behind like rook f1
i can play i'm assuming there's more
than one way but i just want to go to f7
yeah there's
a lot more than one way to win this yeah
can you even starting with e6 just to go
rook d4 rook d7 that as well yeah but i
very much like winning the ball g7 for
nothing so exactly like i'm very i'm
very partial to being three pawns up on
the king side there
yeah three connected passengers yeah
uh
yeah that's flogging a dead horse for
sure uh this looks uh feeding a fed
horse
feeding a fat horse i like that okay
russian expression no that's a beta
expression peter expression feeding a
fed horse
that's a okay so that game is in the
books what about uh hansa's game one
more move for hans to make time control
and i can't imagine somebody not taking
one f7 with check yeah why would you why
would you know why would you not would
you know
and the ender's saying yeah that's just
completely winning for white the
opponents on the c5 will queen faster
than the pawn on the h5 will make a
threat
absolutely yeah can we take a look like
yes show me the first line of the queen
like yeah queen seven king eight shade
king eighteen
h6 of course sorry yeah we're never
going back i'm
speaking there yeah yeah and the top
engine move is apparently f4
but i'm wondering i'm wondering if i can
just play c6 am i missing anything no c6
h4 i just wonder like how do we in this
position just uh all right it like it
likes to go back to f6 since it forces
your
so let's go forward just for the sake of
h5 yeah king h5 and now okay we move out
of the way h3 h3 c7
oh we just don't have checks like md7 is
just so safe right it's pretty safe and
of course if you play h2 i can i can i
promote first and i chuck made you yes
nobody doubts you don't survive that
yeah and this is already on the board
king h6 already on the board plus eight
is the current evaluation but more
importantly mufans
gets an extra 30 minutes to think about
it and i'm sure he will convert this one
wow yeah looks looks convertible and
nothing in his previous play gives us
any indication that he's not going to
win this the chess speaks for itself
let's not let's not uh you know
the young man it won't go there all
right and
for
uh nepo
move forward with his half an hour very
much needed bounce back uh rebound
whatever it is
and for ali reza
not
not nothing a confounding game because
he just kind of played passively i think
yeah he did not play wow he did not play
this game particularly well you have to
say
and then for uh
for fabi this kind of lurching and
misfiring at times if you will
uh this uh this position now let's
peter
i'm looking at this position and i'm i'm
still a little bit confused by
everything uh break it down for how how
would you you're looking at knight g6
check you're looking at rook d1s you're
looking at f6 you're looking at all of
these kind of tactics f6
like let me just put some moves on the
board and how do you break these guys
down well here takes a seven we this is
why we shouldn't have allowed queen d6
exactly that's why the inclusion of
queen h4 and 26 is such a huge deal for
black is that
for a
vast majority of this play once this end
game with uh an exchange down was not
end game this this position where white
had a knight on e5 and right
and the queen supporting it but the
queen was on a6 out of civilization much
of our our advantages right there was
very much based on the fact that the
queen wasn't really participating in the
defense at all exactly and queen h4
allowed it to get back into the game i
think what happened there is that five
perhaps did not realize
that queen f4 check up this intermediate
check on f4 exists the in the line of
the 96 knight of eight right because i
think without it black is busted still i
i still would prefer like i was so drawn
to the idea of f6 gfg6 from from a
purely aesthetical right of a uh
point of view that i think i would have
played it here just because i like it so
much exactly i like i like these types
of pawn breaks
so much that i would have been very
drawn to it right but also
uh it wins yeah it's just flat out wins
yeah but if we go back if we go to queen
h4 queen e6 and we play uh this whole
line knight six check uh knight the king
king g8 knight takes ffa and we start
looking at let's say black taking on f8
here with the rook and we play queen e4
in reply oh black takes on e1 and after
queen takes c1 black takes on the fate
with the king and we go queen e4
we're happy
we assume we will win this and actually
in this particular case we probably win
this even comfortably i don't think it's
particularly difficult for
queen ending to win so perhaps it's just
just a straight up miscalculation that
he thought i mean you don't miss queen
for check but maybe you don't realize
that after queen d1 queen did quincy do
queen g1 yes it comes back and we still
don't have a good way of dealing with
those checks without losing the f5 pawn
exactly so i think what happened there
was just a straight up miscalculation i
think he thought queen ish was winning
very comfortably and now he's coming to
the realization that
there is still a game going on and he's
let his advantage slip
we're going to take a quick break and
we're going to see you on the other side
of this break
stay tuned
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of fame
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the continued coverage
of round two of the sinkhole cup and uh
plenty of action still going on despite
the the two games uh finishing
reasonably uh peacefully with uh mvl uh
who was in our studio somewhat early he
he did feel like maybe he missed some
opportunities these are the two draws
you're talking about between lavon and
magnus
and and mvl versus wesley so well nvl
felt a bit aggrieved he did not spend a
bit more time at a critical critical
juncture there against wesley but he
wasn't really
uh i think i don't think this counts as
a full-on missed missed winning
opportunity speaking of missed winning
opportunities of the three remaining
games that we had actually thought that
white was going to win all three well
let's go to the linear game he has 26
seconds left yeah let's let's show we
yeah we can continue talking about the
fabi for five game against lanier but we
should be watching it from from the
bird's eye view because rookie four on
the board looking for a rook d8 only
move found by linear found on very very
little time yelling you made it with
like 15 seconds on the clock oh dear
as he is
i really feel like removing ourselves
from the picture altogether and watching
the players here is the
is the way to go uh rook d8 linear needs
to calculate this very very carefully
but he appears to be out of danger now
and it's once again it will be very very
good to him the fact that
his moves
will be more or less forced from from
here on out 96 check
appears to be the only way to even put
any pressure on his position 96 check
followed by after king g8 the move rook
d4 because
getting mated on d1 was probably
advisable
and then once again if if you don't play
h36 here you're probably in a tremendous
amount of danger queen h2
knight of i don't think we're making a
comfortable draw there
but you're saying we're going to go into
hg rook d6 or d6 fg rook to hd6 in these
types of positions
i think generally uh very often i even
comfortably drawn by black it's a bit
it's a bit awkward that our queen side
structure is so extended because it
might start
i think we do have nige king g8 as you
prescribed
a theater on the board i think the
entire sequence is extremely likely to
appear on the board
uh one thing we will mention is that
rookie four that move that uh fabi made
after the queen of six after prolonged
thought
is a kind of a cute one because it seems
like the knight on e7 is hanging yes but
it's not because rookie 7 g6 will win it
back very comfortably don't allow queen
takes n7 made and or
as you said peter
and another very important part of this
decision is if you play queen g3 here
which we were playing after rookie 6
previously yeah that runs into a bit of
an issue oh and it's very pretty
actually yeah it's a one of those puzzle
rush tactics rookie force setup a queen
h7 trick but we do have rook d8 and we
are seeing these moves
unfold because of the time trouble peter
and rook d4
now lanier will have to judge whether he
can play queen h2 can show is really the
only pro alternative to hd6 but i think
you know your experience and he's done
it yeah he's taken the night the
experience tells you that these types of
positions are
a very very good shot at the draw
because
um
i think you can defend them in two ways
you can defend them sort of passively
like i can play let's say uh a6 okay h4
right i mean if i get the pawn to h5 i'm
a bit worried right well it's sort of
like i want to centralize the queen
queen d5 and as you say i want to
combine it with these background
meetings yeah let's let's let's not play
a6 let's play rogue d6
uh from the start
rook d6 here
unless g6 wins but i don't think it does
um
it's a bit worrisome but i don't think
this is
all that much and first of all checks
along the first second rank will always
precipitate
with with white hank
hiding his king into the 80 corner but
the point i was trying to make if you if
you don't play g6 you play h4 yes
exactly i just want to play g7 g6 yes
and then a7 a6 and then play happy yeah
and claim that i'm okay because you you
will not be able to breach this type of
a type of a fortress very easily exactly
the black king is so weak that black
never really switches to giving mate to
the king on c1 because white pretty much
always has a perpetual but black is also
rock solid in these types of positions
right the one thing i can argue maybe is
i'll put my pawn on a4 you'll put your
pawn on e6 but then i'm going to try to
put my king on a2 maybe intimate on a
good day king a3 king b4 yeah i won't
trade a pawns i'll keep
my position there
no black will still have to play
carefully for sure but
uh and financially starts with this he
he goes a4 straight away after tase g6
he doesn't even spend a tempo on queen
g4 right i assume lanier goes a6
although i think maybe there is some
argument for
rook five
nah it's risky rook f5 eight takes p5
rook takes g5 what is what because i
would play and quincy [ __ ] h7 yeah
king if i win the b5 pawn this might
actually be a draw i think
uh it's a way to immediately change the
character of the position in that once
the quantity 5 is gone
my king is completely safe right i no
longer have to worry about the king's
side but it does
punt our entire our entire queen side
like and
how happy are you punching the entire
the entire side of the board is unclear
right and i think i saw a6 yeah think
the corner i think you played a6 here um
alejandro uh
there's something about the move a3 a4 i
like uh it doesn't make
the position that more difficult for
black not to an engine the engine just
says zeros are close to zeros with
pretty much everything they liked white
just to smidge in this position but it
was with one of several moves a4 was one
queen h5 was one queen g4 was very close
to zeros and in the current position the
engines are very adamant if you play
anything else
it's just a draw but
okay you still have to do it
queen h5 seems to be the way to try to
do something but the problem is that if
you just play the move rook d6 your
desirable g6 in this position you can
give a check
you could go here you can give check
king b1 rook d d2 and even though you
collect a lot of things here check king
f8 check king e7 check king d6 you're
still not defending b2 so at the end of
the day your the best white is going to
happen black's going to have is a
perpetual
yeah it's a on move 41 you would assume
that this is findable if if linear has
to
make that dive on move 37 like if if we
find screen h5 and lanier has to
uh realize
allowing g6 is necessary and you still
have to go for it it might be a bit
tricky so
it's i think it's time to ask this
question now when yeah queen h5 it was
strange because i actually thought queen
h5 was provoking king f7 but uh
then i realized okay i couldn't i can uh
billiard
queen uh
yeah and get over yeah that kind of a
perpetual sort of eternal self being is
not really so that is a that that's a
kind of a very
nice escape
but the crazy part is it's a force i
mean you you you have to allow g6 and
you will get something like this and
then you do get something like this and
maybe something like this and then you
give a perpetual after after realizing
that these two rooks are really
dangerous yeah and also it's very
important that actually
maybe not that important i wanted to say
that in particular with the with the
rogue steel on d2 the position that
alejandro showed uh right let's say here
we go we give all those checks yeah we
go
we give all the three checks up to each
set up to g7 right and then the king
goes specifically to d6 right and very
very cutely there is not even a single
check white can give because the rooks
on d2 and have to control every single
checking square but after king a1 rook
takes b2 there will be some checks but
they are not very relevant because the
counter play is just so strong
and
that's how you make a draw now in our
winning games
how
winning is yan yan is very winning yeah
ali reza got a pawn but check out that
king on e6 it's even gonna try to
checkmate its opponent
yeah yeah the threat here is
apart from king of seven also rook takes
a6 to create mate it's kind of not not a
bad threat at all it's a visual yeah so
you play rook a4 i guess if you want to
continue fighting here you play rk4 and
then probably the cutest way to win i
didn't check but i think the cutest way
to is king f7 rook f4 f6 gf e6
that's one way of winning yeah
you can also just take the a6 pawn sure
but like i kind of like this c6 rookie
for
let's say rook takes a6 here
and then i mean i will win the full rook
for this pawn very very uh comfortably
and they're not by the way there's still
an a2 pawn in the position too so even
if we might be winning even without it
but because it's on the board
[Music]
it's a definitive so that one's really
uh
over over and how is uh
hans doing in his game with shaq well
that's pawn some c7 and the other that's
not on h2 so he's very very close just
needs to find a couple of accurate moves
to push it forward
and that should be the game but he still
has to find them
there is no immediate forcing of the
pawn forward if you go king b7 i still
have this check
you cover this way i go queen b7 so you
still have to finagle a little bit the
engine's move is absolutely not
intuitive is to play the move queen c5
but i'm sure there's more than one way
to win this position the pawn is just
too advanced
yeah queen c5 mc5 is extremely cute
because we're threatening king a7
exactly and you're covering and no
cheeks yeah yeah
that's a that that's a nice one whereas
yeah i i understand what you mean there
uh alejandro about a little finagle you
still have to find uh the right wiggle
room for your king so to speak
but i must say queen c5 is not the
intuitive move no no
you think yeah king b7 played these
things have been known to go uh to go
wrong it's
absolutely yeah the queen endings are
victorious some of the silliest things
uh uh in existence and people do misplay
them because of how
sometimes counterintuitive they are but
hans should be winning here if he plays
well one of my worst commentary moments
ever
i was uh commentating on a game between
anish giri and wesley so it was a queen
ending where anish was an extra pawn up
and
i just didn't understand the position
and the players didn't either
so we started with zero zeros
and then wesley would make a move and it
would be -47
and then anish would make a move and it
would be zero zeros and then it would be
minus 47. and those are good players
exactly exactly those are good players
making sensible decisions right just
very very wrong right but still sensible
and i i wasn't guessing uh why it was
zero zeros oh why it was -47 it was
pretty pretty brutal pretty brutal queen
we have three check on the board we do
as uh alejandra is saying because this
pawn is just one move for coronation
this is three yeah it should be a win
no i wanted to say that you know the one
thing that shock definitely is doing
well in this game in terms of
causing practical problems is that he is
playing as fast as possible this is the
final time control han still is on a
very comfortable 17 minutes this
shouldn't be a big big issue
but
yeah shaq needs to
sort of work at the board
and and prepare moves against most of
the things his opponent can do and just
try to play as quickly as possible to
hope perhaps to get hans you know down
to i don't know two minutes with the
ball on c7 still not being a queen and
then maybe some nerves will start
creeping in but yeah in general
of course uh with the poland's before
providing additional cover against the
checks that's very very very this should
be it should be winning um
alejandro is hans uh like linear is he a
person that enjoys uh
playing time trouble or
getting himself into time trouble we saw
that he did
play on increments in the first time
control i just don't know hans that well
as a chess player because remember this
is the first time that he plays a
classical tournament as a super
tournament he has played some of these
players before he just came from the ftx
cup in miami and looks like shaq just
resigned after something chuck just
resigned after something happened yeah
queen d5 queen b3 and the game is
somehow over despite our boards not even
updating looks like we will i guess he
didn't even want to wait for king c6
six weeks still have checks you know i
don't know i understand but uh otherwise
i can't guess why you re
you know i'm not sure what happened
there because yeah this is deficiency
there's no better or no worse than it
was really like any of the previous
positions right yes but i think i think
this one is just over right
what after king c6 yeah what do you do
here check from a4
queen b5
check from aaa g7
queen that is actually
a7 though yeah i still c5
h3 queen b6 but then there's check from
a4 i thought i thought
i thought i was being cute i mean you
could still play one two three i don't
know i mean i guess i wouldn't resign
either i would have well will get a
chance to ask but not but i mean i'm not
exactly i'm not the role model here
uh back to uh the the two
two rooks versus queen and and yeah
bobby surprised me by trading the apons
i would have thought that he would want
to keep because potentially i think he
wants very specifically to be able to
take on b5 straight away uh he played a
baby and g6 specifically too and now
rook f6
actually wins the g6 pawn because after
queen beatrice f8 you can't protect it
but you can take on b5 and c4 and this
is why he kind of
weakened the b5 pawn
so the thing is thing like yeah the
thing is even this i'm not sure how
easily winning this is but obviously
this is the absolute absolute best
scenario but if i play rook f5 queen b8
rook f8 it's an instant draw right
because queen takes b5 rook f1 we have
an immediate perpetual it's an immediate
perpetual unless you want to get made it
right it's just a perpetual because we
can't get to the v1 square no we would
like to go b1a2 but we don't have access
to b1a2 yeah ooh
ah so rook f6 is just a draw it's just a
draw it's just a drum okay
okay triple zero is not a surprise no no
no it's not it's not a shock
and it's his last move uh before mu 40.
um so we should perhaps uh
somewhat zoom in on
yeah he's gonna start with chuck on f1
and there's no rook of six players and
he's dying yeah this will end in a drop
pretty pretty much soon right right
yeah yeah because you can play king b1
now no first of all look at fun
yeah how we've lost it
resign designs very nice wolf peter well
played well sir
uh you can uh your choice of mates yeah
your choice is your choice e2 or a6 uh
wow
uh that's quite the visual you don't see
that every day
by the way which is why
if i had the pawn still on the yeah i
wonder why
uh
we get here this is where i kind of was
thinking that i
at least i'm not opening but then but
then i think what happens is what i was
describing earlier i go g6 i go r5 from
kf5
and nothing and nothing like ever gets
touched right like i just put i just put
this guy on e5 and i say both rooks like
this like this is your setup and then
you can just thinking g8 you can't
tickle my a-bond you're not gonna go h5
anytime pardon me even if you a lot like
queen g4 i can play king g7 h5 gh queen
takes h5 i don't know
rouge six exists but i don't even need
it right you just pause i think i can
pause yeah and then you say go ahead
do do whatever you like this setup is i
think completely completely impossible
to share the shaker
but what has happened in the game with a
b
has made it that much easier or simpler
if you will for lanier uh in this case
so draw expected one win
or uh for our round two so we're keeping
and young jan will probably win that
rook ending bringing bringing the sum
total of decisive results to three and
then two in this round yeah alireza
played king c8 rook a6 played and it's
perfectly
good to resign here yeah king b7 rook
drops back and then the f-pawn quinn's
basically like you you can't really
defend against the f-pawn queening with
your king on b7
exactly
it's it's way too much it's way way too
much by the way i see a bar on the side
of my board
was up through the border um
wow okay so two
two wins expected for this round and we
we do uh in a moment we'll we will have
an interview with one of the uh players
who has already won the game jan still
has to put some finishing touches on his
victory but okay hans
is with us in the studio and we'll we'll
get him miked up
before we
and
he is ready to go alejandro
hans what a game today take us through
some of the key moments you chose this
very wild extremely modern type of chess
opening tell us what your thought
process was choosing it well it's not
really my choice yeah it's his choice to
put the ship c5 instead of the bishop
before uh so
before yeah okay of course uh for the
audience yeah here like uh bishop bishop
before is the
it's more um his
tendency so the things he had no games
here so i wasn't sure which one he would
go for right and uh i spent a little bit
more time on bishop before than bishop
c5 but i did remember
obviously i should have
known much more about the position than
i did
but he also seemed to acknowledge him to
to
to stop at uh after queen e3 so queen e3
was the end of your preparation let's
put it that way yeah because it's just
the main line it goes the b5 c5 or maybe
i miss i couldn't knock him b5 is
absolutely the main line no of course
yeah so b6 uh it's uh just a bad very
bad move yeah i assumed you know so here
i was like thinking and thinking and it
was to to
of course i knew it was a mistake but to
punish it in these positions is so
difficult so
so how did you try what was your thought
process here of course i thought of um
h4 but i thought that what i played was
simply the most direct uh
so okay my thought price is okay usually
okay let's say h4
it's saying uh okay it's saying now
h3 rookie
yeah so so
to understand this you have to like
understand that um
uh
this is let's say the best plan because
what i played
with bishop d3 i mean and and uh yes and
now again queen g3 is it's a mistake but
it's like there's so many uh
and and here i was forced after rookie
to play this uh rook he won you actually
spent a lot of time in this decision
yeah um
[Music]
it's not really the move it's what i was
going to play it's whether i was going
to play c5 or cb5 so perhaps i should
have played rookie h1 so he played
bishop h3 no no he played b5 yeah b5 and
then we went through this c5 yesterday
described it as a bowling ball going
down yeah yeah so um but but yeah of
course i should have uh
this h4k3 idea i should have seen yeah
sorry to interrupt you real quick there
we have another result from caron has
drawn his game against linear dominguez
there's certainly going to be a
disappointment for fabiano but let's
continue with this analysis you're
telling us about this position
yeah so
i i knew i had a big advantage after b6
but to capitalize was difficult but okay
obviously let's say i play cb5 instead
of uh so c6 b5 bishop a6 a4 c6 that
queen h3 yeah uh takes take uh uh take
e6 yeah i saw this take an e6 yeah yeah
so now uh de6
should be it
takes yes yes king
okay there's two options there's there's
even uh there's king a2 there's king c2
there's okay let's say king a2 how do
you evaluate the same game
equal yeah perhaps
but the problem is that a lot of these
end games with the bishops uh these
double pawns are going there's going to
be so many fortresses right because
um i don't really have a breakthrough
so now i evaluated this is just going to
be a draw so i thought you know why not
[Applause]
this position okay the fact that d5 is
the best move and d6
it's very counterintuitive yeah because
you're
your eyes are just looking at this this
king right he made he played a5 which is
a mistake yeah oh and now i'm
no i'm better yeah okay so i should have
played queen h4 first okay fine
but bishop g2 and now now i was just in
control yeah queen h4 yes and i played
ah queen g 24 is also very precise okay
very nice rook b7
taking a5 oh wow i played so well
you can be surprised with yourself well
uh when you're going down on time it's
like the thing is that in these first
two games i know they're my opponents
are playing terribly you know i'm like
what are these guys doing i thought
they're supposed to be top players so
i'm trying to punish
and uh
no of course yeah this is all correct
yeah rook eb8 but he was just way too
optimistic were you sure you're going to
clinch this point
okay uh
the queen game i was completely sure now
already
this boy position
yeah this position i was quite confident
because i had foreseen this position and
foreseen that
uh
the
you know to have the pawn on g6 um
is very nice in these end games because
you always have some triangulation
checks you know right so uh
and i thought like um
in any case i should be faster
with these two double pawns and
it's really nice to have these two pawns
because it's just you cover
this queen b5 king b7 i found the right
construction so he plays queen a1 and
maybe here what was i supposed to play
king before is correct yeah yeah but you
should note like i have like um 30
seconds here so uh perhaps i wasn't that
precise no you were you were fine oh i
was yeah yeah oh oh i don't see the the
valuation changing that's a good thing
i i definitely should have found this
sir h4 because h4 is my first instinct
right
but
i think after that considering the time
situation i i kept my nerves well and i
didn't let him intimidate me another
victory there for the white pieces is
that yandere pogba she does put the
finishing touches on alireza farouja and
comes back to the tournament hans is
your first win against the 2750 plus how
what does that do for your mood
it's okay
but it's not a surprise to me that i'm
beating these players so
perhaps uh
you know
when i haven't said i've improved quite
a lot lately so i've sort of become numb
to these these rapid changes for me in
my mind i'm already you know a top
player so
winning a game uh confirms that
but um
my confidence
of course can be strengthened by such a
win
but
confidence comes from commitment and
hard work so
not just winning
well there you go hans niemann with an
important victory against shakira madiya
good luck in the rest of the term we
certainly hope to see many more
victories from you thank you
thank you very much
hans
our congratulations a
very entertaining game including as han
said
shakriyah playing a variation a
double-edged variation that he wasn't
that prepared for yeah
it's it's a kind of a strange choice to
go for this with black if you're if
you're not sure what you're doing
because as the game showed once you once
you deviate from the straight and narrow
your position could very easily
deteriorate quite quickly and this is
what we uh eventually saw in the game
because i think the the position uh
after like we we keep on kind of
glossing over some points in the
sequence with the people running down
the board but
the game is in the back so we don't
really need to
go speaking of the game being in the bag
let's take a look at our current
standing is hans niemann a very very big
surprise
to our panel is joined magnus carlson in
the lead absolutely and with the round
concluded this is the uh the final
standings after round two uh magnus won
yesterday and drew today uh plus one uh
tied for first with hans who i failed to
win yesterday yeah you know good could
arguably be even somewhat aggrieved
agree that being only uh
a point and a half out of service yeah
yeah uh
a bunch of people and 50 including yandi
bomnishi who made no draws so far right
one one loss yesterday and a very nice
win against study reservation today ali
reza is in my in the minus and shaking
is
also
in the miners absolutely and we do have
a fabi in studio to take us through his
game today with lanier and he's with
alejandro what a crazy game this was
fabiano welcome to the studio tell us
about your preparation it seemed very
deep when did you stop remembering and
start calculating well i was a bit
disappointed because i i hope this h3
would come as a at least a small
surprise
all the way back here
yeah it's a very rare move but it has
been played but i was hoping that
he wouldn't be as familiar with it or he
wouldn't recall exactly how to play
against it
uh but he
he knew everything
like up until night of five i'm pretty
sure
up tonight at five even inclusive knight
if i don't hear well i was i was really
hesitant because after bishop b6 i can
do some
out of control stuff involving like
queen e2 we need two instead of f4 g6
yes we have three
b5
bishop e4
rook b8 and i just thought okay i don't
know what's going on
bishop c6 rook of fate
and it's i was worried that he that his
attack will crash through and i'll get
mated
so okay i played a rather controlled way
which was trying to equalize this is
still in your file like i knew that this
was a sort of a bailout a bailout okay
and at this point i thought okay i
should probably bail out and
um i guess i'm like a tiny bit worse
after queen d5 if he plays
queen e6
like 26 sorry queen six queen takes and
ambitious page three ambitions i mean i
guess white equalizes here but
i'd rather be black yeah i was surprised
that he went for bishop f2 very forcing
yeah it might be a draw but uh it looks
like white has the easier time of it do
you remember this move or was it not
considered
um
no i i didn't really analyze this
position i mean i just kind of knew that
white is more or less equalizing here
and uh
and i really didn't expect bishop f2
yeah it just looks dangerous
and okay i see
double question mark somewhere
don't worry about that just yet so
this followed this is absolutely forced
and now instead of going for a draw you
decided to keep the game alive with rook
takes you one i didn't see exactly how
black plays it after rookie one i
thought maybe rook 88 yeah rook 8 was
definitely the best move according to
the engine but yeah i thought that white
isn't definitely not worse right like
it's hard to imagine white being worse
here and i i even thought i could play
slowly like h4 or something it didn't
seem
it didn't seem like i i have any like
only moves here right um so he plays
rook f8
yeah
queen d7 i thought queen b6 i i really
didn't see anything there queen b6
knight f7 king g8 and then rookie seven
um
[Music]
why is this winning
95 next move i guess knight h6 checked
another 16
kj like
so wait if queen f2 then knight e5
uh
go so far it's so deep here but do you
have a perpetual queen of one queen d3
traits the queens
king b1 i think we can go knight d5 yeah
i i think we can go knight and then okay
let's say he takes two pawns
and d5 knight f7 right and then queenie
fight knight f7 okay yeah queen d5 here
just to show knight f7 picks up this
queen can't defend this way
so you got you saw the move queen b6 and
didn't fully see him i saw this and i
thought like black picks up g5 and uh
and i didn't fully believe in it because
my king looks very open right so
yeah i just um
and if quiche went first then
than king c2
do you want here can i assume c2 we have
two yeah we've got to be one one take
and now probably
might be five four anyway five again
yeah ninety five four ninety five seems
winning but i might even have knight h6
knight six king h8 because he defends h7
by spinning for check yeah
and he has rook f1 counter play
um
i guess i i mean no but 95 queen of five
it can't be 95 here yeah so so maybe
it's just
okay knight h6
kj take queen e4 king a2 we're maybe
losing here to rook f1 and then rook f1
knight f7 and knight
we're winning we're waiting
but i think it might hinge on something
like this something very concrete down
the line yeah it's like uh basically 20
move i mean okay not 20 moves but it's
it's a very long line and uh and
probably all hinges on like a detail at
the very end right a little bit later in
the game we did have this position he
played b5 you found this great move
knight c6 must have caught him by
surprise taking the knight seemingly
away from the attack but cutting off the
queen and after rook c8 97 rook ce8 he
decided to start with the move queen h4
uh why did you decline the move f6
yeah i thought queen h4 was winning um
but wait f6 gf and g6 right yes
yeah yeah this is this is probably uh
there's just no moves he's completely
dominated yeah i just thought queen h4
queen d6 for q4 was winning and i
i um
well i thought there was even like a few
things i might be winning but then i
couldn't find anything it is not winning
at that point
yeah which is unfortunate
like um
[Music]
yeah i just didn't see what to do like i
was thinking instead of rookie four
knight g6
king g8 rook d1 is very interesting
sorry instead of instead of rookie four
rookie four knight g6 king g8 and rook
d1 rook d1 yes and then he has queen d1
king d1 rook f5
oof trapping the knight knight f4 rook
e4
g6
hg queen d8 king h7
and my knight gets lost like
it it was kind of
remarkable to me but yeah i guess my
king is is really chronically weak yes
yeah
i just need to take a draw with queen h4
absolutely
father you didn't find the correct move
in this one to finish off the game do
you think that it was just too difficult
or do you think that form is affecting a
little bit
no well the first one was difficult but
the second one with f6 was not too
difficult i just rushed to queen h4
um
yeah i don't know i also was affected by
his time he was very long time and right
for some reason i thought i should play
quickly but
um but that wasn't a good idea yeah f6
is really not difficult because um
there's like two very logical moves
one's queen h4 one's f6 and
if you start to calculate f6 it does
look
it does look really devastating
absolutely probably two rounds so far in
the sing field how do you feel
uh yeah today wasn't ideal um
it's a bit disappointing that i missed
uh more than one
win but
you know uh hopefully gets better
well we hope so as well fabiano carona
with one point out of two guys any
question from the panel uh quick
question for you fabi uh hans niemann he
comes into this tournament is the lowest
rated player
in the event big target on hansa's back
and he's performed
admirably in the first two rounds your
thoughts
well i'm not terribly surprised i mean
he's capable of beating
uh the best players in the world and
and that showed today
um yeah he seems to be in good form so i
but i don't think this is like so so
shocking that he that he beats chakriar
it can happen
all right fair enough thank you and good
luck
for the remaining rounds and peter uh
two players tied for first uh you didn't
see that coming i didn't see that coming
well we i mean two players being tied
for first
we could have predicted but the the the
names of those two players that's what
perhaps come as a bit of a surprise even
though i i mean what fabi just said
about hans is is very understandable
hans has been on a massive massive
heater improvement
and uh yeah
he is obviously an extremely dangerous
player okay as we take a peek at
what we have for you tomorrow uh let's
take a look at the pairings for round
three peter do the honors uh let's take
a look uh so shakira majirov plays white
against maximoshi lagrave very nice
guess what the two players died for
first peter yeah and then we get magnus
with the white pieces against against
hans should be a very very obvious
pairing of the day there but we do have
one more interview
uh with aya sumo somewhat relieved yanni
pomnishi who won a very nice game today
against reza yes he did indeed and he is
with alejandro let's uh
cut to nepo a big winner of the day jane
pogbachie you've incorporated the
catalan as part of your repertoire with
huge success how did it feel today
well
better than yesterday yeah a little bit
more successful a little bit more
successful you would say were you
surprised about his very long thing here
in this position were you familiar with
the position that we got after rook b1
well i think he uh quite recently he had
a game against magnus and where he chose
this a696
so
maybe in zagreb okay i know no idea but
one of the recent rapid games
but i felt like
this is
probably not the
most
expected line
in the catalan out of like
three or four extremely solid lines so i
just had an idea so then i sacrificed
the pawn like q institute and uh play
for i know for some compensation and
yeah in fact it's quite a playable line
for white of course like black is solid
but
yeah i think he
played like in
an interesting way but maybe some of his
decisions were like
questionable take us through some of
those decisions where do you think he
started to lose the threat of the
position clearly this is still playable
he's under pressure bar up a pawn where
does where do the wheels start coming
off i can't recall maybe there is
suddenly bishop e7 movie is important to
make instead of bishop d6 so it's uh i i
think yeah after movement of 12 i think
here bishop i think we should be seven
yeah with some weird ideas maybe queen
protects the pawn on h7 and then you
make a castle like this like they should
be sounding queen h5 yeah because for
example here after bishop d6 maybe
bishop is um you know gets into trouble
after c4 c5 white for instance important
tempe yeah uh so there was a game that
went queen h5 actually exactly in this
position
yeah that's maybe a good move
were you surprised by f5
no it he took like a long thing and i
felt like maybe it would be queen if i
queen each five or h6 or f5 so after
five i wasn't sure like how do i uh how
do i proceed here so bishop g2 was the
move yeah
yeah and here i was kind of expecting
inspecting e5
which they just thought was the best
move yeah i thought it's like e5 is very
principal and actually five i didn't
really see the way so rgb7 is quite
tempting but after rook b7 i think he
can
not take on b7 but he can just go e4 so
if we're cutting up the bishop
yeah so that's not so clear if i
achieved something yeah so probably
instead of rook b7 i would i would
choose uh maybe just taking on b7 here
always the bishop so now i have this 10
people queen b3 check i'm not sure i'm
massively butchered or something but
clearly okay i have sort of an upper
hand here so it's like some b file but
once again black is very solid
and what he did uh
well i don't i don't really know
so
he made a castle yeah yeah we got to
this
game yeah the rook and game i felt like
it was very suspicious for him because
he can't really get this um
i mean simple freon to structure yes so
basically the way how you draw this
horse and games you just try to not lose
all your pawns so win as much
performance opposing opponents in the
end as you can and then defend on the
you know on the king side three-on-two
but
exactly this three-on-two is quite
unpleasant yeah so it's like uh we were
talking about that i'm not sure i'm not
sure it's winning
with the best play but uh i mean anyway
what he did what he did was quite
quite hard for me to understand because
he just decided to stay
uh in a very like in a very common way
and yeah after the game he said that
okay he
didn't really see a plan for me to
improve but which was
quite surprising because uh okay i have
no plan i just can push pawns here so
maybe maybe maybe one one cannot called
you know
can't call this a plan yeah but yeah
that's
it worked in this game so it has to be a
conversion baby yeah
yeah so then i mean e5 it says
was it
i thought i thought maybe g4 is more is
more precise but i felt like okay five
king e4 should also be more or less
enough
uh i mean okay computer you know has all
the wisdom in the world
so
well it's hard to say what was next
because yeah he just stayed until i
actually put my king somewhere somewhere
around e6 and this course yeah i think
this was enough there was some time that
i thought about you only in a very
dynamic way you loved all these
complications and suddenly you add this
cat on you outplay ferugia positionally
simply having a better understanding of
structures do you think that you've been
able to adapt to other types of chats i
think i'm
still you know still learning
this type of chess but saying of the
all the way i mean of course of course
one can only dream about such an end
game i mean especially this rook ending
with
when you have some pawn majority and
also an active rookies yeah even despite
its equal number of pawns it's still
like
i mean it's uh
it's really hard to play uh as a as a
weaker side
i have to ask you what happened
yesterday
uh
i thought like maybe
you know the only good news about
yesterday's games was like it's it's
really hard to play wars
uh so i was quite optimistic about
today's game
because of this but actually yeah i
think i just
had not enough experience uh into these
type of structures and uh thanks to
magnus i got some yeah probably i would
prefer like get it like somewhere before
but uh i mean yeah it's like type of
position which is
white is uh i don't know
uh pretends to you know to improve but
in fact it's very hard to improve hawaii
but
yeah i guess uh just
when it's like five different lines
saying zero zero zero of computer yeah
it's of course uh play could be improved
from both sides yeah you know especially
in the opening but i mean of course the
c5 uh
i mean it could have it could only have
sense when when i don't trade away my
knight 26 then i have this tactical idea
c5 d4 and the okay my knight becomes
active uh but as it was in the game uh
yeah i guess he just uh
uh he just got some some nice two
bishops and turkey this before b5 idea
and yeah it also was based on some
blunder because after bishop d2 i was
going to play 94.
and then okay i noticed that okay bishop
a5 b6 bishop e1 and uh yeah my position
just falls apart
so
that's why i mean okay of course one
could defend it better for example
player okay instead of whatever rookie
seven and it's like it's worse uh it's
much worse but it's i mean far from
losing
but yeah it's not uh as you know at the
same rush it was not you know back in
the day
well yeah john always learning the panel
do you guys have any questions
not just
just well played and uh nice balance
back victory yeah i i don't want to say
that those are those are good interviews
to have back to back yeah
congratulations and uh ian i will look
forward to your game tomorrow
well peter i just in what jan was
sharing today about his game i thought
what he basically showed
was great control throughout he just had
a clear
awareness of what was going on and he
knew once he got into this rook ending
that extremely on point yeah yeah very
very on point he knew that you know
despite a four against four rook ending
with currently
no immediate ways to perhaps
dramatically improve if black stays
passive as we've seen in the game if
black stays passive eventually something
will come up and uh exactly and he was
proven correct uh so yeah very very
nicely uh nicely done by bayan in
particular i felt so yeah if you take if
you take uh
yesterday also uh sort of uh
into consideration the fact that he had
to
recover recover emotionally i think more
than anything else because losing a game
like yesterday does affect you
absolutely it's never a good feeling
let's jump back to alejandro and
anastasia for their final thoughts of a
very eventful round two uh
alejandro
exactly it was and um it was really nice
to see now young happy coming to the
studio right now it's been a really long
day and we had many spectators
including rex sinfield himself he was
watching your broadcast uh in the chess
club we had many visitors today though
many of them went to the
uh
vultures
hall to watch this exhibition devoted to
the anniversary bobby fischer played
against uh sparsky boris baskey so um
also it was really nice to see the
players in the good mood leonardo met
with his chess fans and gave them
autographs and he was very they had this
really nice chat and also magnus was in
a good mood um
i mean i was all this is published in
our social media you can check some
other interviews which with players who
didn't come to the studio today
plenty of information in our instagram
accounts in our twitter accounts and
also you can follow our flickr account
full of great very nice beautiful
pictures from leonardo and other
photographers
absolutely a shout out to
the fuelers who have been
filling up the flicker with absolutely
great photos go check those out for
myself i thought it was a great round
similar to yesterday tons of content i
love that fabiano corona bailed out and
then we had a massive comp amount of
complications over the board and that he
was able to show us why he didn't play
queen d7 why he thought that there were
more things to look at than just that
move to me a very moved round but story
of the day is that hans nieman is in
first place with magnus carlson and
that's the matchup of tomorrow how
exciting it is indeed uh looking forward
tomorrow peter and same time same place
here 1pm 1pm central absolutely and hope
to see you there once again thank you
all for sharing your day with us tell
your friends where you're hanging out
we'll see you all tomorrow see you then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you